oh you
[Music]
can perfect
yo what's up guys happy [__]
monday this is the dope as usual podcast
i am dobaziola thomas this is marty
o'neil drastic graphics what's up what's
up guys this is the dope as usual
podcast we're here to talk about life
problems drugs accomplishments and
everything in between and i know i
messed up that order but i always will
all right
there is no order
they're kind of i try to do it by
smaller words and it gets bigger
accomplishments at the end i just forget
every single time we should just [__]
spray paint it on the back wall so you
just look at it every time i don't know
how it's four words and i i [__] it up
almost every time sorry guys i wing
these intros i never know what i'm gonna
say even though it's the same [__]
almost ironically yes it's the same um
let's get right into this episode guys
uh it is monday
well officially this is we're filming
the day before thanksgiving but when you
see this [__] it's gonna be the monday
after the holiday so i'm sorry i'm sorry
you're back at work you got a bunch of
days off if you're at school [__] i'm
sorry
so
guys i'm gonna talk about this episode
let's get right into it this is gonna be
a completely
well no not a completely different
episode it's going to be the first time
we're trying this out so
i'm going to bust into what i'm going to
talk about and then later on in the
episode we're going to bleep we're going
to do our little bleep [__] and then
rosie's going to come in
you guys ask for rosie all the time
rosie
does not like talking on camera she's
not comfortable with it so i'm not going
to ever force her but we asked her like
you won't just pop in and talk for a
second so maybe we'll get a whole
episode one day but for now guys we're
doing what we can so she can still feel
okay and not feel weird
so that's gonna be later on so this
episode's gonna be
partial guest i don't know we've never
done that
let's go this is the [__] most long
awaited i mean next to goblin rosie is
the most requested of all time i feel
like i think so honestly yeah out of all
the people that have been asked for
for sure so
um that's what it's going to be like
today guys and i am going to
hop right into what i'm talking about
my topics i have a few things uh before
we start though season two solo episodes
the next ones we do we're gonna try to
do a little more uh you know what let's
just leave it at that it's gonna be a
little different we're not just gonna
sit here
rattle off topics as much we're going to
try some some some more [__] so we have
some guests coming up
um i mean i'm excited about
the youtube dude i'm very excited yeah
me too um what you say i'm getting hyped
up you guys ask for him all the time but
we just talked to larry lawton he is
the youtuber prison man
the jewel thief i i don't know i was on
youtube i scrolled upon this guy's video
i watched one video was [__] hooked
he reminds me
of my uncle ron a straight edge mixed
with
a prison bird my stepdad
like very articulate they know what
they're saying they know what they're
doing it's nothing to them because they
lived it that's the [__] i want to hear
because i there's a lot of things i
can't talk about on here just because
people are alive and i'm not trying to
get them killed or sent to jail
so i can't talk about everything
and i don't want to go to jail so
he's already been to prison for [__]
years and he has the wildest stories man
so i didn't watch everything i only
watch a couple of things i want to be a
genuine like oh [__] let me hear this
story when he gets here so next month we
have larry lawton coming in and we have
a lot of other people but i'm just
really stoked on that we locked him in
yesterday
and i'll i'll stop with the guests i
won't say what else is coming but
here we go guys i'm gonna hop into this
first topic marty and i have been
this is a struggle we've been dealing
with
okay you guys know uh dope's usual merch
we had it for a second it's really nice
but the company we've talked about
before the company was not doing their
job they were [__] up we talked to
somebody else and they lagged thing with
marty and i we've said it before if you
lag on us you might as well fired
yourself because
not waiting on you and if you made me
wait your work ethic is trash i don't
want to be there when it's time to split
money
like if this is how you're doing your
work what happens when you want to keep
more money [__] you anyway we teamed up
with some people like we talked about
before but the merch the line is
dropping next month
officially i'm so [__] excited
guys
it's so weird as a as an apparel
designer to have like myself on a
[__] chair i know i've never had
myself on a shirt ever yeah out of all
the years i've never put myself on a
shirt a face a cartoon nothing
there's a picture of me and marty on a
[__] shirt but it's not just like a
here's us it's it's it's like a
tournament tape cover yeah like tour
mixtape covers yeah 2007. i am excited
it looks really [__] cool we have all
over sublimated t's coming
puff prints coming some other [__]
coming freddy krueger we're gonna wait
on all right we're gonna wait on freddy
krueger we're gonna drop it a little
later
a monster design inspired by the set
that is just never before seen that is
gonna [__] do work i think
we have some really really really really
nice stuff coming
super cool marty and i's whole plan is
to turn this into its brand itself just
opens usual it's just a clothing brand
by itself we have some super sick
sticker packs coming so overall the
merch line is dropping before christmas
you'll be able to get a bunch of [__]
and uh yeah it's gonna be really really
cool i'm excited man and same company
that does boo johnson [__] too right
bucha and i won't say who else but they
do some gigantic [__] music artists
huge
so when i walked in i go so this is
where the [__] they get their stuff done
you're gonna be like that's where
they're printing these crazy designs
we talked about this last episode but
since then we actually have an approved
yeah everybody's ready to go a first
collection
we were going to try to rush it out for
black friday but then we realized that
didn't make sense and we didn't want to
do it so we're like let's do this right
and take a month basically wouldn't work
yeah i mean because right now they'd
just be printing we'd be shipping two
weeks late
no thank you
so
dope's usual merge is coming very soon
we're coming back in the best way and
it's gonna stay all right we have we
have
actual cool [__] and we can do [__] like
for instance we've been tossing around
the idea of like doing a random giveaway
to one of our youtube members yeah every
week
takes accessories every sticker packs
and cool [__] to just
it's gonna be cool man yeah it's gonna
be very cool guys and uh thank you for
watching thank you for hanging out thank
you for buying merch thank you for
buying all that stuff we appreciate it
it really
it really does help you guys so thank
you um i know those first two topics we
got into quick
but i feel like i've been watching back
these episodes i'm like yo
get on with it [__] i'm over
here like
repeating myself going i don't know it's
just what i do but i am it's like it's
like updates at a goddamn town hall
meeting or something like fields yeah
let's let's recap what we touched on
last time in [__]
yeah real quick behind the scenes real
quick just speaking of town hall meeting
i know this is it's not even in my notes
real fast i know you guys have probably
seen this on tick tock or [__]
instagram there's a video of a town hall
meet you know they film them in some
small towns yeah and the [__] guy the
chairman of commerce
i don't know stuff the guy in charge
with the suit sounds right is the one
speaking and some
other man stands up from the crowd rosie
you watch this
and he starts going in on this long
story about how he used to get super
[__] abused and bullied in school
and then at the end he goes uh so you
want to say anything and the guy the
chamber of commerce guy is the guy that
used to bully him and do [__] to him all
right and he calls him out in the front
of
everyone
he says his name starts school he goes
remember when he used to beat me up and
throw me and stuff and you know strip me
naked and he starts talking about like
[__] i don't remember exactly what he
said but i remember him talking about it
he goes so do you want to apologize yeah
the guy [__] resigned hmm
yeah
so imagine all these older white dudes
that are kind of nerds were [__] not
all what i'm saying those dudes in power
not all of them are great guys of course
not i love a video where [__]
[__] up gets just you see the sheer
panic in his face oh you can see it on
him when you're a grown man walks up to
him and
yeah the guy was big as [__] too so he
must have just been kind of a quiet kid
but the way he talked about it it's like
he's been thinking about it for 35 years
and he finally [__] was like oh oh
you're on tv today i'll see you today
uh-huh sorry anyway just real quick i
just wanted to say that i thought it was
really [__] hilarious um here we go
guys uh this happened 40 minutes ago
this is a topic i want to talk about
because it's some [__] that goes on all
the time and let me light this
[__] joint
i uh don't pronounce names right unless
someone tells me their [__] name
so i'm gonna say this the best i could
ahmad are barry arborer ah [__] it
aubry arbory i don't know how to say his
name you guys saw the video a couple
years ago the disgusting ass video with
this [__] black dude is just
all he was doing was exercising jogging
down the street and these dudes in a
truck i think it was
two or three white dudes just stop him
and they were asking like where the [__]
why are you here some racist
50s [__] right
i'm not going to show the video or
anything because it's really [__] up
but if you saw and you watched it these
fools just murdered this [__] guy
he's telling to get away from him he's
like trying to get back off and he
starts fighting with one of the sons and
the sons obviously getting his [__]
ass because this guy's out here is
working out there's some fat [__]
piece of [__] racist
trying to [__] man up with a [__]
cornerback and [__]
and uh
they start fighting
the dad pulls out a gun or a rifle and
just kills the guy
[__] shoots him
i think he shot him a few times i don't
remember i just remember feeling hella
nasty and like i can't watch the rest of
this [__] as soon as they started
popping i was done
i can't watch that it was so [__] sad
and disgusting and the thing is this
[__] happens all the time and
[__] don't go to prison for it
about 30 minutes before this episode
started all three of these [__]
just got life in prison and i don't i'm
never
wha i thought you're gonna do a sound
effect
there's so many i could have hit right
there i know but you're like oh it's not
approaching too many i know that's a man
a cricket's not appropriate all of them
are inappropriate yeah all of them
everybody's gonna be mature here yeah
okay next time don't be mature all right
[__] man
all three of these guys just got live in
prison i watched all the accounts being
read on cnn right now
as soon as they read count one the guy
in the black goes
the judge goes uh please escort whoever
just made that a gesture out of my
courtroom and they wait like 30 seconds
to kick him the [__] out
i i don't know man i know if
there's a lot of injustice going on
every day i mean in america we look at
it because we see it on the internet in
other countries it's life it's just
normal
that's what happened we're very lucky to
be here even though we're like people
getting shot every day
go to another country all right let's go
to another [__] country that's not us
and it's pretty bad not saying we're the
coolest
there's some pretty bad places out there
man that's why people you know come here
for asylum and [__] so
that's what's going on all three of
these pieces of [__] and looking at
their faces not one of them looks sad or
like upset about it they didn't look
remorseful
just murdered this [__] kid
for no reason just killed him so uh
good
what's good these three [__]
are going to prison forever all right
they're never getting out they're gonna
die of eating that trash ass food
it's over [__] all three of you
on to the next topic um
marty's shaking his head i know i know
bro they're gonna be in solitary their
whole rest of their lives oh honestly
now they get to prison they're going to
be embraced by the white white
supremacist fools like yo you took one
out
jesus christ that's how it's going to be
they don't
cop killers are like yeah good [__]
[__] pedophile's like oh we're
gonna kill your ass i don't even want to
get into i've heard some
yeah well i was larry lawton
my stepdad told me some [__] that
happens in pedophiles and it is so
[__] sad i feel bad for those guys
even though they're pieces of [__]
it's like damn bro
maybe he's just sick in the [__] head
you know what i'm saying like a lot of
bad i feel like those fools are mentally
[__]
and they need to be somewhere else
but those dudes that out there living
their lives and covering it up and just
molesting
those guys i have no remorse for but
there's some weird kids out there weird
dudes out there
that are mentally unstable they get to
prison get [__] and slashed up yeah
[__] and it's not their i mean it's
their fault but some of these fools are
ten in their own head and just
i feel bad yeah i feel bad for those
guys
no way not to feel bad about the [__]
situation at that point jesus christ i
mean obviously what they did was [__]
100 times worse yeah deserve it
but not every [__] case is like yo
that kid is [__]
super slow yeah put him in a home i
don't know man i remember finding out
something about one of my family members
that was already dead
and feeling like damn if he wasn't dead
me and my boys are going [__] yeah
like i remember when i was like 16
with that feeling like damn if he wasn't
dead what would i do right now
yeah that's the [__] is dark all the way
around but i mean i don't know i don't
feel bad for these [__] at all
some i do
some the only ones that are like on the
borderline of being slow
because it's like bro you should have
been your hands should be held through
life
you know you know exactly what i'm
saying some of these guys that are slow
that's the ones i feel bad for every
other one can eat a [__] dick and
they do every day all right so let's
just say let's just keep it at that all
right uh why did we give him this
[__] topic i for oh from oh
those dudes go to prison yeah they're
gonna be fine they'll be fine nobody
wants to rape those guys
oh really jail dude we're talking about
this guy you got half the jail wanting
to rape you i mean you got some people i
don't know how the [__] goes okay so
this is how it goes
we're talking about it last night
i'm a couple my friends been to prison
i haven't known a lot of people's hella
long
prison terms
southern mexicans and mexicans don't
rape each other it's a forbidden
you're not allowed to do that okay
so mexicans ain't getting raped out
there right i mean this is not happening
in prison if you're like
affiliated or bro it's just a thing
it's a good truce to have yeah don't
know that's like the thing like we don't
do that nasty [__]
i mean i'm sure there's some dudes out
there doing gross [__] things i get
that
but in the south a lot of black dudes
are on each other like i don't know what
it is about the south like it's a
[__] free-for-all
not like mexicans and whites it's the
black dudes in the south are [__]
crazy
they do not give a [__] like you are
probably gonna get raped there if you're
not [__] affiliated yeah
uh white supremacist fools not too much
but there are some white i know i'm not
saying like everyone rapes people but
mexican no listen i saw a shawshank man
andy had to put up a [__] fight hey
i'm still gonna go to the grave he never
got raped
he got beat up a lot all right yeah dawg
no
no he wasn't going for it there's a
movie called uh
sparked or
baked or it's like a weed centric movie
but it's got jaleel white and danny
masterson in it
and they talk about that constantly like
yo
do frame did not go down like that no no
way and when they were talking like
right
no in my head he didn't get played [__]
no morgan freeman saved him and talked
his way out of it or something but he
did all right we all seen the star trek
redemption if you haven't
you're welcome
great could you imagine not having seen
it yet i'd be so glad i'm jealous i know
right there's some movies like
there's some movies like that that i
wish i could just erase my brain and
watch it again for the first time that's
my boy
one of my favorite i wish i could just
watch it for the first time over have
you seen it adam sandler
i've never even heard of that one i mean
that's my boy's one of my favorite
movies ever he is this guy in the movie
it's r-rated he's getting [__] up he's
not adam sandler he is oh you told me
about this and say i'm playing a
character i love it so you know what's
crazy like chilling with dante peter
dante his well you know his east coast
well you know you gotta kill
his accent is exactly that's my boy
accent in that movie
it's stolen not stone i'm saying it's
like dead i mean they're friends yeah
but it's dead the same
the accent is
oh [__] it's the same east coast like i
don't know i don't know how to say it
but they have the exact same accent
why the [__] are we talking about this
sorry
i couldn't tell you
shawn shake it shouldn't seem oh great
we asked quentin tarantino this
love this movie let's work back to
[__]
jail love
yeah [__] okay
next topic guys sorry next topic uh what
time we at
18.
yup still got it
so from the last episode
remember we talked about the dopest the
dopest shop the brand i have coming out
oh yeah real quick
thank you guys so much for the support
it went up like another thousand
something since we talked about it
thank you guys for the support
i [__] up i had no idea i didn't know
what was happening
i'm sorry
so apparently our website was going it
was up it's not live yet so there's no
products to buy
i didn't know
bank of america has to approve us so we
had to make the site live for 48 hours
it went live on sunday night
monday is when i talked about the
[__] episode and i kept getting the
messages like i just got this flavor in
this flavor and i'm like
is it a coincidence and i'm getting a
bunch of dms of the flavors that we we
made the names
how the [__] would these people know
what we're releasing
you know what i'm saying like i didn't
know what was going on how the [__] you
know tropical sunrise like how do you
know these flavors
and then people like yo i just bought
this and isn't like yeah they're just
talking [__] yeah right
we got so many [__] orders from a
site that's not ready yet i didn't know
the bank we had to activate it
so while we activated it i talked about
it on the podcast
and when we did we had thousands of
[__] people going to the site and
trying to buy [__] and some did get to
buy [__]
so if you did buy stuff guys you're
going to be reimbursed
let me just say that it's not ready
we're not even [__] we're packages
aren't even here yet
so first off thanks
but claudio our partner hit me up like
dude what's going on
what do you mean they bought [__] so
that's what's been going on guys and
this morning what
10 minutes before the podcast started
bank of america approved us we are
officially a [__] brand and the bank
is accepting our money
so very quickly
exactly
so i'm excited about that super [__]
cool but yeah the dopest it i [__] up
i didn't know that that's what's gonna
that wasn't gonna happen
but thank you guys this is really cool
i'm not i mean that never even would
have
dawned on me like who not would have
known the [__] was
on a [__] test run when we prepared
the episode i didn't know i did i wasn't
i didn't know
i guess
anyway it's a good sign so thank you
guys so much appreciate that
guys we're doing good we're doing good i
think we i'm not gonna you know we're
gonna hit an hour and a half today we're
gonna get an hour and a half or under
today it's gonna happen i feel it
here we go oh by the way we're driving
straight to merced after this it's
thanksgiving tomorrow and uh
traffic's building let's just say that
have you ever drove up north on
thanksgiving off the grapevine
you might as well walk
just [__] walk there because you're
gonna be it's gonna the same eta
i promise
but guys i wanted to keep this
organized are you ready all right
thanksgivings tomorrow by the time you
see this thanksgiving's over you already
did the whole family thing
taking pictures with people you don't
really want to take [__] pictures
with or you just don't want to take a
picture you already snuck off with your
cousins to get
high as [__] at the gra in the on the
side of the garage we all do this we all
have done this if you're underage you
already snuck eight drinks and you're
gonna throw up and everybody's gonna
know you're [__] up so calm down
and yeah if you're one of if you're one
of those people that oh [__] go see
my family [__] when i was younger that's
how i felt like
i gotta hide everything and now i'm just
like i don't i don't care what's up guys
i don't know after the pandemic i
realized yeah i don't hang out with
anybody enough
so this is gonna be cool i get to go
hang out i've been to my mom's in a
minute
this is gonna be a good one does your
mom do like a wholesome thanksgiving is
she that mud um
growing up my mom just made lasagna
at any time that's what she made if she
if she did make stuff i remember my mom
cooking about 20 30 times my life
okay you know i don't really remember my
mom ever really cooking stuff did she go
out for how like she did holidays though
like [__] no no all right
[__] no
i was trying to give her the benefit of
it no my grandma did okay without my
grandma dolores and my grandpa tom that
talk about my childhood would have been
way worse
wait what about like christmas when you
were like we've never had a tree or
anything i don't think god damn but my
grandma's because we all go to my
grandma's my grandma's is this
holiday okay we all live in the small
town we go to my grandmas we know that
so your presents were under santa went
to your home i think we did have a tree
once
like when my stepdad came into town i
came into the the picture we got a tree
all right
i think
i don't remember put it that way i don't
[__] remember man i have to look
through family pictures to find out
jesus christ you know what i'm saying i
don't think so i don't think so but
thanksgiving if you're one of those
people that are going to go [__] i gotta
go see all these people just just tough
it out all right you'll be fine you'll
be back on the road and going home
just be [__] careful here we go
thanksgiving i'm going to talk about my
other side all right my mom you guys
talked i've talked about her many times
my mom
my mom's mom is my grandma dolores was
she was awesome she was a jewish lady
like polish and i don't [__] remember
all right we tried to do hanukkah we
talked about it i made fun of it and she
never did it again i was a kid i was a
dick
and you know my grandpa is a [__]
spaniard from el paso i don't know if
you've ever said that i have a lot of
family in el paso i've never met
ever
never because i never met them you know
i don't know what else to say i don't
know them
but my grandparents from el paso he was
a [__] spaniard he looked like uh we
talked about eric estrada
they do the [__]
white people christmas
and i always say white people christmas
because you know the difference mexican
people christmas is different white
people christmas is way different
so i was split down the middle white
people christmas i love it because you
know we're watching stuff and watching
christmas story and i i drank a soda
every five seconds as a kid my grandma
delores had it on lock
but remember i have another side of my
family my dad's side my grandpa greg is
from the [__] jungle of mexico he's
little as [__] he grew up killing snakes
my gran i would say my grandma yeah i
did my grandma grace
is portuguese and german but grew up in
acapulco so she's a [__] mexican lady
through all the way through she's brown
so here's thanksgiving and my grandmas
my grandma graces all right you ready
for the mexican side i don't i've never
talked about this [__]
at least i don't think
i've talked about the cows right marty
how my grandma raises cows and all this
okay
so this is my thanksgiving my grandma's
i know a lot of you gonna relate
there is no [__] air conditioning or
and
well it's not that cold in november but
there's a fireplace my grandma and
grandpa do not believe in using any like
electricity so we just fireplace it up
but it's pretty [__] smoky all right
i'm just gonna say that it's pretty
smoked out in there and uh it's cool our
whole family comes over that's what we
do on thanksgiving my grandma grace
everyone goes over their house on
thanksgiving like our cousins and all
that chicken to my grandma's got a big
ass property
so what do we do what do you do with
your cousins
boys what do you do with your cousins on
thanksgiving you play [__] tackle
football somewhere like what the [__]
else are you gonna do you play tackle
football [__] each other up wear extra
sweaters so it doesn't hurt
so that's what i did all the time oh
every [__] year my cousin ronnie
louise all these fools i was the
football player in the family though so
i was the one like all right this is
what we're gonna do remember you're
holding the ball going you go here you
go you remember those days yeah yeah
just holding the ball down the lace like
all right you're gonna go and bust out
and he's kind of slow so you're gonna
cut back in
that's the kind of [__] we were doing
and under one year dude i don't know
what came over me this is a lot of years
mixed but i'm gonna tell you
eight years of doing this and i don't
know i was about 11 or 12 i don't know
what happened but my dad really
i don't know how why he pissed me off so
violently
pissed me off we're all playing football
he said something to me
i [__] fell
like ripped my [__] pants my dad's
sitting there laughing at me after he
was just talking [__] for no reason
and i just pulled the
christmas story again
remember in the christmas stories but i
didn't say fudge
i went
[__] you loud like that pissed and it
kind of like slipped out and want to say
it as soon as they said i went
and my dad like
i just envisioned you as a kid like i
feel like you just nailed that
impression that's exactly how i did it
and all my cousins went
oh [__] they all looked really like oh
[__]
no turkey sandwiches no turkey gum
whatever he says on the christmas story
i don't know that's how i feel food
and then i went
and i [__] took off running dude i
don't know i didn't wait for a second i
went nope
took off i don't remember why where i
ran but i've always said if you're in a
situation just run and think of it later
i love that i just sprinted my grandma
has a hell of stuff i was cutting
through like
where the cans are i was cutting by my
grandma's car chasing you
i didn't look
i just started running i was like nope
i shot [__] i was like 11 or 12 years
old man and me i'm a very stubborn
person even as a kid it was so much
worse
i told rosie i've been thinking the same
brain no differences since three years
old
same logic nothing has changed
everything is there
so as a kid i'm like yo get the [__]
away from me tweaker
get away from me homeless man that's
asking me for money i'm five you know i
mean i always had that get the [__] away
from me so my dad and my dad was never
there and when you try to check me on
[__] like that i've been going to
football come here dad
on the shoulder i've been going to
football for three years now i will tell
you what to do you never play football
[__] you you just watch the [__]
redskins
washington football team sorry
and uh
that's a die hard fan yeah we take a
shot at that [__] team every episode
now that's my dad seeing his [__]
names yeah that's my dad's team dude
he's still got the big ass old school
red and yellow [__] uh indian dude on
the back oh i love that jacket anyway
i turn around and he's not even there
and i'm just like sitting on the side of
the house and he like walks around he's
looking like
and he comes over to me he doesn't like
yell at me like yo what the [__] is
wrong with you
i'm like
oh i tell him why i'm mad he's like all
right my bad i'm sorry but you can't say
[__] like that like in the office i'm
your boss you can't say stuff like that
to me stanley did i stutter that's how i
felt
[__] you
and then
everything was cool like we went back
and started playing football again and
when i came back everybody's like
you're not dead like no you know my
dad's cool right he just uh told me not
to do that again my dad was not a parent
to me
my dad was a child i remember schooling
my dad when i was like four or five
because he was having a house party at
his [__] house my dad drew so many
parties my dad was cool with the cool
dude in merced
there were so many my dad was a very
good looking dude so there's [__]
[__] everywhere that's all i remember
fabian alamar party okay that's my dad's
party
that's my dad and i remember his friend
is [__] in there chugging beers in his
little
like s10 pickups like you know the ones
people slam and [__]
and he's like
doing don't the house that he just
bought rosie
the same [__] house
that's the house my dad used to live
when i was a kid
the one he moved he bought the house
next door and the one he owns next door
that little house is that's the house we
were in
doing donuts
whole park the whole block packed full
of people
and my dad's like get in the bed of the
truck we're gonna do dawns i go dad
that man is drinking
if he flips over how are you gonna feel
if i die
and then i remember he went
and his friend went [__] bro
it's like your son's your son's very
mature for that
i was like three or four and he's like
he's very mature and my dad's like you
know what
you're right man you know go sit on the
lawn dude i don't know what the [__] i'm
thinking and then he hopped in the bed
of the truck and did it jesus christ and
i was like come on dad [__]
i just remember uh
a lot of that a lot of like
come here dad let me give you some
comments give me some comments and
advice
don't do that math
you just you know stick to work stuff
like i did
back on topic i'm very sorry guys back
on topic uh thanksgiving so my grandma
grace
she's as mexican as it gets i don't know
go leave a comment marty i can't wait to
see your face
my grandma only boils the turkey
what does that even mean
it's [__] disgusting and it's just
white
hold on hold on she boils the turkey
like you make stew
a whole turkey okay just boils it for
[__] two days that's it
that's it
so you take you you kill the [__]
turkey you put its bodies oh no she
brought her in here okay but i'm just
saying but she just boiled it like i
think people call it blanching she
[__] boiled it
and it was the worst you can boil
something for two days and i don't know
how long she really did it i was a child
but i remember looking at it going oh
that's not my grandma delores
how about people put their [__] hands
up dead turkey's [__] rip their guts
out that's my understanding oh i've
never done it before me neither but i'm
just i tried to explain to my friend the
other day go hey
i really love cows they're [__] cool
they're like dogs imagine saying yo that
cow's so sick i don't want to just chop
your leg off yeah i wish i could just
bite into its flesh
i'm so hungry bro yeah
[Music]
so this brings me on to my next thing my
grandma boils the turkey you know rolls
hot spicy salsa [__] everything
and she makes this rice it's layered
with cheese uh sour cream everyone loves
it sour cream rice cheese bottle it's
like a layer it's really cool i hate
sour cream my whole life
every time i go to my grandmas i eat
mashed potatoes and rolls
and they know that everyone knows that
and now that i don't eat meat at all me
and rosie are just eating mashed
potatoes and rolls straight there's no
butter in it there's no butter tomatoes
grandma [__] yeah because she knows
cause there's been times that go over
there go i'm gonna just drink this juice
yeah thanksgiving [__] socks here
but that's before
we thought to plan anyway that's what my
grandma made every year every year every
year until i was about 20 and then she
started just listening to everyone and
going no we'll buy the turkey for
somewhere else my grandma got very
i've been in the apple store
i've
civilization that's the kind of [__] but
i'm not done i'm not done before
thanksgiving
i told you they raised cows
and they would murk those cows
sell it to the asian people
that rented the house from us
my grandma kept the head the tongue
and you know the blood
so thanksgiving i just remember big tubs
of blood pudding everywhere
looking around i was like oh god
you guys are different chips in it
i can't
i can't even think about it
i remember you said the word blood
pudding before and i thought you were
[__] joking
don't
we can't talk about dipping chips
i'm done i'm done anyway oh my god grab
crazy thanksgiving use the
that's my grandma's on thanksgiving and
playing football
so
that's pretty much how that went forever
man how about your thanksgiving morty
my thanksgivings were not as [__]
adventful
my parents were like
vegetarians like we're talking about
what your parents were yeah my mom was
that why you don't eat meat too uh
well i guess i was vegetarian when i was
a kid then when i was like a teenager i
started eating meat and [__] and then i
turned back into a vegetarian when i was
like 22 or so 23.
yeah but they were vegetarian so that
she would do random [__] like chinese
food on thanksgiving bomb yeah random
crystal maine and [__] yeah
but so you did not have a very
picture no i mean no we didn't do
anything and we weren't we didn't do any
after i was seven years old we didn't do
anything with any of my family
ever that's when they all got cut off
that's we kind of just yeah walked away
and so we didn't really you know like
when me and jamal linked up that was my
family
when like thanksgiving and [__] it would
just be me and him after i was like 13
and [__] like all the [__] you're
talking about it was just that
but yeah you know growing up in [__] it
was just simple just really three of us
me my mom my dad and [__]
but
i remember feeling like they were older
like when you're when you're young and
you have like older parents they were
like they were your parents are older
yeah they were like
they were like 30 in their mid to late
30s when they had me oh that's fine
they seemed really old though to me like
oh yeah going out to dinner and stuff
with them it was just like i don't know
they just they seem way older than i
feel like i seem to my kids now
like i don't know just never like
fun i guess you would say just like
anything like that no real standout
memories no crazy [__]
none of this [__] you're talking about
but i will sound some vegetarian [__]
just if i can rant a moment because i
had a situation in goddamn nashville i
don't know why the fans feel about this
in my mind it's not if you go to a
regular restaurant and like if they're
going to give you like one of their
little entrees that they give everybody
that they should let you know if it has
[__] meat in it if it's some [__]
that doesn't normally have meat in it
like rice
or
queso or beans i don't know
some of these [__] restaurants sneak
[__] meat and appetizers and that
[__] pissing me off
that's happening many times yeah or take
a bite
oh no cause i know that yeah when i get
vegetarian meats i have to have rosie
taste it first because i don't remember
what it tastes like i don't i don't
that's a fair you might not even yeah
you might not even [__] know
the texture
like when i buy to go that's like
[__] meat there's been times where we
get vegan food but
i'm [__] doing beef right now that's
fake beef
i don't like that [__] that's too close
too close
uh in nashville this i sat there
explaining to this the waitress my whole
order there's no meat in this just i'm
vegetarian so just want to make sure
there's no meat in this break the whole
[__] down to her
then come to find out there's meat in
the goddamn queso yeah for sure people
do this and she didn't give a [__] she
was like on some oh well like i don't
know the [__] to tell you like when i
found that heroin needle she goes do you
want another room remember
in my bed or the hotel that's how she
reacted
sorry
beef i mean [__] same idea i got that
mad yeah i never get mad i was [__]
pissed
that's not cool though they should just
not uh label that shot it makes me uh
i'll throw up
i've dry heaved and puked up a little so
i remember the last time i ate meat
uh
we were at like what i thought was a
[__] fancy restaurant at the time in
buffalo
and they like
no it was like a one-off restaurant but
it was you know
and i had i forget what happened but i
had veal
like they've brought out veal
and then i realized what it was and i
remember the moment i'm like oh i'm
never eating meat again
such a weird thing [__] every bro
yeah i mean no let me play with you all
day no just don't move
i'm gonna eat the [__]
oh god
i get attached to animals too fast yeah
yeah and it's just i don't know it's
just i'm one of those i wish i could be
like that with like [__] sugar or
some [__] like where i i'll write
something off her [__] life in a
moment and it's done i really will done
like because it's for me it's like a
streak how long yeah exactly that's what
i i told that to the [__] waitress
like [__] i got a [__] 13-year
streak going here so i feel like it's
been so long [__] [__] like when i
[__] gum some coke when i was like 26
i went it's been five years but
i had to try it because i heard it was
great i had to my friends do [__]
cocaines when they had the flavored [__]
and i went
strawberry
oh my god it tastes like [__]
strawberry my face is gone where's my
face you still get high off that or just
numbs your mouth out okay yeah
that strawberry-licious
oh yeah
daryl strawberry
what a good name for this strawberry
flavored cocaine this is that daryl
strawberry daryl
[Music]
so you you had a pretty christmas story
thanksgiving
and i had a
i had a [__] up thanksgiving in my
grandma's every time like oh the cow i
feed
you shot him and cut his throat off
i can't do it i told you i can't i can't
look at that [__]
anyway
um thanksgiving
i got new gunshot sound effects loaded
up but i think it might have been a
little extreme for shooting the cow
let's see do it
oh
it was a 22.
my favorite shot at every eight one from
christmas story remember one two
ten
one
two
ten there we go there's the cow yeah
oh
oh god
yeah
oh man
yeah i used to feed him so much
watermelon
anyway um yeah thanksgiving what time we
at i'm gonna say 39
40.
break this table in half we're being so
close goddamn all
right very sorry
so we're at 40 minutes
i think we can do it i think we can do
it yeah okay i think we can keep an hour
and a half and i only rosie really
doesn't like talking on camera guys so
i'm trying to keep her like at 20
minutes so i think i need to bust into
something else and then we'll stretch it
so we can hit that 1 30. i don't want
you guys going it was an hour
an hour episode i don't ever want to do
this an hour episode that sounds like
even though that's what all podcasts
normally do i want to go above and
beyond all [__] of all time
not just to [__] on just to go
yeah and i'm tired and high too
your work ethic is just step the [__] i
don't know what it is
i don't know what it is dude there's
just something in me i wish that i wish
that it was healthy to not sleep
like if i helped you oh my god i would
just not sleep be unstoppable yeah i
would just not sleep because
i just love if i could just smoke og
joints all day not sleep get [__] done
have people getting the [__] done that i
need to get done
and above all else we do all this work
just to be shadow banned which is the
craziest thing if you think about it
like the dopaziola channel guys i
haven't broke a million on any video
this year
not once marty
and i look at my back end age restricted
i showed rosie ages tricks although i
can scroll down pages of videos all of
them just age restricted
and it really really doesn't it doesn't
recommend you anymore it doesn't put you
on a homepage doesn't put you in the
categories
you're in the abyss
it's like you know you're at a concert
and you're like being a dick you throw a
water ball into the crowd like oh we're
just gonna land that's my video
that's me going yo internet oh [__]
where did it go
just right on the floor somewhere
yeah yeah it's on the floor like i'm
getting the views i was getting when i
had 20 000 followers damn
everybody 1.3 million
never seen it we did a raw og video last
week
yeah i thought that was going to [__]
go oh i love the video too it was such a
chill hangout just hanging out with
friends getting [__] up
i think that was the worst views i've
seen in two years and that's highly
requested
well it's not that it got age restricted
while i was uploading
yeah you know we got aj while i was
uploading and it got um
promotion or use of drug narcotic or
something like that i'm like dude
[__] you guys man i see uh i went off on
tick tock yesterday i typed out because
i see this this girl on tick tock she's
like some podcaster she's like three
million followers and all she does is do
we [__] and chose hot boxes and
but she could tell that she's one of the
girls that's like yo weed's really
popular let's do weed [__] you know what
i mean one of those people
and 75 000 or 75 like million views on a
video of her doing weed [__] i'm like i
said the word weed and now i can't post
can't comment can change my profile
picture nothing on tick tock i've been a
whole week
i still can't use sick talk because i
said the word weed in my caption
basically they go hard on me dude
uh
anyway we do all this stuff i wish i
could not sleep but i wish our [__] was
not shadow banned or [__] with if they
could just leave us alone
our fans enough would be
yeah should be
the [__] out of here
yeah that's why the x factor is weed
going federally legal so they can all
eat a dick and then we can just go ahead
and live our lives like normal humans
that's all i want man that's all we want
to do all right also real quick
check it out um
let me pop up the thumbnail
i just did the honeydew the honeydew
podcast ryan sickler we just did um a
new episode together
it dropped yesterday right
i don't remember what i talked about
it's so odd just rattling off things and
then you look at it and go
oh that's me
cause i go through phases of my life i
think about
you seen american beauty no
i don't know i know i know you're gonna
[__] look at me like that i'm not
gonna sit here and lie like i don't know
i'm i probably saw some scenes from the
show
well kevin spacey
i haven't seen this [__] movie okay
you see the reference with the girl
covered in roses and she's like yeah
yeah that's american beauty all right my
third favorite movie but now that kevin
space is a rape i can't really [__] with
it anymore
anyway um
what he's explaining if you guys see the
movie he's explaining his life in the
beginning of the movie he's talking
about he's narrating his life he's
narrow he's narrating like going over a
for like a neighborhood they're just
showing opening scene and he's like in a
year i'll be dead and here's what i'm he
talks about his last year of life the
way he talks about it is the way i think
about chapters when he is get i don't
want to ruin it for marty but at the
very end when he's like my grandmother's
skin felt like paper and bought me as a
boy scout looking at star all that [__]
that's how i've been thinking my whole
life like in little chapters like
oh act one
one through seven i was until i was
seven years act two that's how i think
of it all that is how life is yeah
because i look at it from above me
because i remember it's very well i can
see myself from right here right now
because it's so weird like
it's like a little drone camera
that's why when we're doing cameras like
no no drop your camera go left a little
i do how many times i do that like ah
the angle's off can we go like right
here
because i know what it looks like what
it's going to look like yeah i can see
everything like all the paintings behind
me i don't know what it is i'm sure you
guys can do it too but
i do that everywhere so i always watch
myself
like as a kid like when i fell off the
bed i talked about it cracked my [__]
open it's never from my pov it's always
from like
looking down on myself talking to my
sister cracking my head open and [__]
and i'm laying there like just dying
it's always from [__] like i
do you see what i mean it's like uh
pressing the select button on gta and
you get different angles pov above side
that's my life that's the best way i can
describe it guys i'm pressing select in
my brain yeah all the [__] time and
uh so that movie really got me when he
was like wow he's just going through his
chapters of his [__] life the movies
and anyway
um
i have no idea i can't remember why i
brought it up now but that's how i think
about everything and uh
oh so seeing ryan sickler
i mean doing the ryan cycle show the
honey honeydew
seeing all the stories and just racked
off is just so weird to look at and go
that's
chap that's from chapter three [__]
it's so weird man yeah
everything's because
like with rosie before i met rosie
me and rosie been together and it's like
wait
all this stuff has happened but it's
just so i don't know it's
you guys know what i'm talking about i'm
over here rambling but you know what i'm
trying to say it's very uh
when you go through those big chapters
of life with somebody and you can look
back like damn i've been through like
three life chapters together
but yeah when i talk when i think about
before filming and doing all that [__]
it's like it was yesterday different
person yeah but it was like it was
yesterday no not the different person
thing i still think the same i still
thought of all of it
that manifestation [__] is very real
like
picturing yourself
doing something and watching it happen
is
[__] cool
it's [__] weird it's like writing
your own book
if you're trying to be deliberate about
it yeah i mean oh [__] yeah yeah yeah
and i find marty when we were where we
went to our massage thing i can't be on
my phone
and i just have to sit there and think
i think i need to start doing that more
you know how i told rosie after i got
out go
i just came up with like four business
ideas i just came up with like three
other things and i
thought of a different way of
camera [__] like a different way of
approaching when i talk to people when
i'm doing camera stuff i thought of a
whole different
i don't know what it is man you put my
[__] phone away and not have to worry
about doing work [__] and i just my
brain just went
yeah it was [__] crazy i needed that
[__] uh chamber yeah the float tank i
got to do the float tank man i was
sitting there thinking of like
branches yeah seeing push trees this and
i was like oh if i do this
i could see things like stacking like
like when i was on [__] mushrooms
yeah yeah yeah it felt like my brain
would just that's why rogan's always
been such a proponent of the floating
because he's that's what it i mean
and for me like i feel like i'm always
so just on i never have time to even
like i've been thinking to myself i need
to do exactly that just to think back on
life to remember even just for the
podcast like really think back on
everything
you know i never do that we're always
it's non-fucking stop
forever
you know we've been at three woke up at
nine came straight here did all our
stuff packed all the [__] orders real
quick you got here we're gonna do this
as soon as we're gonna do oh we're gonna
go back to the [__] spot go to merced
do all that [__] get back come back film
right when we get back episode comes out
do it all over again start it up do this
do so when we when i was no phone i
couldn't answer an email i couldn't
answer a text i couldn't do anything
it's the best thing i ever did my brain
just shut down
and then i just started
thinking of all the stuff that i
couldn't process it's like a writer's
block
for my life
i don't know if you guys have felt that
before i'm sure you have but it just
happened to me for the first time
forever and it was really really really
cool
marty what time are we at
i'm gonna say 47 50.
i think we're good i think we're good
guys i think we can complete rosian and
we're going to start with this next
section of the podcast this is very odd
we're about to bleep this [__] change
the whole setup
have rosie come in
and uh i got some questions
i got some stuff
how about a little [__]
manscape
hey what's up guys this is the mid-roll
ad reading shout out to our sponsor
manscaped as i said many times guys
manscaped is here to make sure you're
digging balls isn't gross
www.manscape.com forward slash yola is
usually 20 off plus free shipping today
it's 25 off of everything in the entire
store cyber monday guys it's almost
christmas time right now stock up on
everybody's stocking stuffers if you've
got people in your life dudes in your
life get it for your boyfriend your
husband if you have those people now is
the time to take advantage of these
sales and you already know we've seen
the weed whacker we see the lawnmower
3.0 and 4.0 but the recently released
products are the two in one shampoo the
deodorant the toner and remember this is
all for your balls let's not get away
from what we're talking about it's still
[__] hilarious every time the
performance package is something i
suggest if you're getting gifts just
just for me to you it has everything in
one but as i said earlier if it's just
something you want to try out just right
now take advantage 25 off
www.manscape.com forward slash yola just
want to say thank you guys for
supporting the brands and support us i
say often but this is the time right now
thank you for clicking the links thank
you for everything this is manscape.com
they've been supporting us for so long
so special shout out to them this is
cyber monday guys take advantage of it
25 off
you're smoking a hybrid what kind of
weed is that it's a hybrid i'm gonna
trust your nose i don't know what the
[__] is it it's like is it that purple
it's kind of purpley yeah i could smell
it wow
i knew it
clipped that clip that i want that
[__] tell me you can't really
smell the string yes i can [__] you
i can smell it like right here it's like
a little purpley but mostly green
but not big orange hairs but it's mostly
green with a little bit of purple i
could tell
i know it
i already know what that nut looks like
man
[Laughter]
oh this is form like gdp
that's why it's formed by gdp
yeah that's the old school [__] we
should talk about the asian guy perps
wow i haven't seen that in a while
the highest percentage [__] they had
last night i smelt it here we go
so guys thank you so much for watching
the address thank you for supporting
thank you for clicking the links thank
you for supporting the brands that
support us
guys with that being said we are back we
are back this is the first time ever
bleeping in a guest
and uh
like i said earlier maybe we'll get more
at a later date but for now
this is what damn there's too many
office references i was just gonna make
another offense reference just let's
stop
guys okay this is uh my fiancee rosie
stoner dottie hi what's up
hey
i like that
[Applause]
um so
guys you guys asked for rosie all the
time
here it is okay i got a few things i
know every we know everything about each
other so it's kind of hard
for me to think of topics to ask you
oh
you're in a relationship like what the
[__] am i supposed to ask that's what i
was wondering what you were gonna ask me
too yeah so i have a few things so here
we go guys you uh ask all the time marty
always like yo i think rosie
first off she just doesn't like talking
to camera it's just a little
nerve-wracking that's about it even
though it's just like us through in the
room right now it's still a little ugh
i'll be okay though
the first times i was on camera too it's
you feel off
you know what i mean
and i'm not just like i can't just sit
here and smoke a joint and be okay
you know what i mean like i have to talk
and interact with everybody so then
that's where it's like oh that next step
is a little yeah but i just always
forget the cameras are here true and
just talk
so here we go guys i'm going to pretend
like i don't know this [__]
um here we go hey lady where did you
grow up at
so i grew up in planada california
planet x yes also known as planet x
uh it's like 20 minutes from merced
where you grew up at
it's way different it's like a whole
entire different town honestly it's like
a farm town yeah farm population what is
it
like way under 10 000. i thought it was
way less than that yeah maybe even less
honestly but then again it is getting
bigger they've been a kid though when i
was a kid like maybe under six or five
yeah there was like
12 streets in planado we had no
stoplights yeah there's no bro there's a
stop sign
no stuff right now there's stop light
now by the police station where but the
sheriff's station right there there's
always the stop sign oh it just stops
there are no stop lights
we have like one little baby market but
we have hella uh pandarias like the
bakeries and stuff like bread
oh [__] i didn't i didn't even know what
the [__] we have a lot of like uh
the guys who sell ice creams
that push them they don't drive they
don't have ice cream trucks we pushed
them
yeah you've seen that right no no
it's right
they got like chips sodas yeah it's like
it smells like a little okay shopping
enclosed and shopping cart but it's a
mini fridge
and they reach in
[Music]
and all my [__] cousins is looking at
me like yo speech man like teach me
[__]
anyway
we have a lot of those she has a lot of
those implementations yeah
i grew up pretty much the only kid in my
town though that was mexican who didn't
speak spanish
wow
and my whole town is like a farm town
i know that's what i mean thomas they're
pretty perfect together
did you both realize that right away no
i don't think so
you know why
i didn't ask because who are you raised
by
my grandparents uh they're german and
dutch my mom's adopted so
we were literally like so they didn't
speak spanish either well my grandma
spoke fluent spanish your grandma granny
did she spoke hell with spanish stop it
you're talking about stop granny's
no that's not true the woman from
courage cowardly dog spoke spanish yes
she could speak spanish
yeah she would speak spanish
she could like communicate to i mean it
was like somewhat broken but she was
like she could hold a conversation
shocking yeah she could hold the
conversation i just learned something
today right now bro she was so cool she
was so cool
because remember we did the bread
ministry so she had to know somewhat
spanish what did your grandparents do
for a living my grandparents are
pentecostal pastors
where's the church located from your
house
about two houses down you could hold
your breath and get from my front door
to the front door
first time went over there
oh my god when thomas first met my
grandparents i first i told them before
we got out of the car if they ask if you
love jesus just say yes
just say yes damn they are pastors those
type of people are like have you heard
the good word today oh and then they go
on in a cool way yeah they're really
yeah they won't bug you if you don't
want to be bugged then they'll just like
okay
go to hell yeah
but you also have to remember
her grandparents are like one of the few
white people in [__] planada well
well when you were growing up because
before it was a lot of white people
they're like oh my god well there was
just one street of white people
hold on i'm [__] confused
so hold on here's all the lanes of the
road of all the streets of the road only
one road was white people the rest were
all mexican field workers basically okay
unless you own land then like all the
white people live out in the land like
in the countryside your mom was adopted
yes by some white people yeah but what
nationality is your mom she's mexican
okay
because then so that means your dad
because you you're i don't want to
butcher what country your other side of
your family's from
mexican right they're a filipino
spaniard and mexican okay well who's
tongan in your family then my
my great great grandma her well he's my
great great grandpa is i believe yeah
that's why everybody's huge her family's
her dad's big as [__] they look like big
big-ass samoan people
my cousins my uncles and stuff like that
patrick's sweat
six four he's huge like he's he's wider
than that door right now
yeah he's yeah he's big he's big
but then we're also filipinos so then
we're like kind of little
okay but mostly the guys they're all big
yeah uh your cousin jordan's a big
[__] big as this table so i grew up
with a lot of different cultures
yeah sounds like that's what i'm trying
to wrap my head around here
okay but your mom grew up in the middle
of nowhere
yeah
straight well my dad's from there too
okay he was originally born in fresno
and then i think he moved to planado and
he said he was like 10.
and they moved next door to my mom um to
granny and paul and that's how my mom
and dad met are you serious she never
told me that that's how my mom and dad
have been learning the [__] out of him
and then
and then my papa my dad's dad yeah he's
he wasn't a pastor at the time but he
did like a music ministry so like he was
like the choir director and stuff like
that too so he would always do the music
part at my grandpa's church and then my
other grandpa he would do the preaching
like for the last hour so your parents
been holy from the start with the
religion we went to church sunday to
sunday
every single day
what did you do as a child for fun
what'd your grandma think was fun
i'm like which part confession rosie
worked at the church oh yes i did
until she moved away i worked in the
nursery
i taught a bunch of little kids about
stuff and then my grandma taught me
probably like the best thing ever was
accounting
nice i did all the work the books and
stuff like that for my grandparents
church but we did everything like
we would volunteer to go do stuff
is that what i'm getting at
the whole time bro oh yeah they were the
people their their back property they
made for [__] people recovering from
drugs they'd sit them in there lock them
in there they got cleaned damn their
grandma grandpa i met my best friend
her best friend ever that's her mom was
one of those ladies that's how they met
one day i came home from it was like
i think it was my junior year
yeah my junior year i came home from my
junior year and normally my grandma
always has some random ass tweaker in
the living room or in the kitchen or in
the backyard doing yard work or
sometimes she locked him in the office
because that's how she helped them get
clean
jesus christ and then there's tweakers
out in this town of nobody oh
okay so oh yeah that's we sleep in the
field we have a glass house out in our
town
what do you mean it was like the meth
house oh you called it's called the
class house that's what they call it
yeah the glass you guys i thought you
meant like what you don't know nice
glasses no it's not like that but it's
called the well meth house yeah i get it
i get it um but they're the ones so your
grandma and grandpa are the ones that
helped get everybody clean yeah they had
a rehab spot here and
what about the food
she would make them pancakes and like
really flat sandwiches is that what
you're getting to i mean
take your time i was talking about the
food drive [__] oh the bread ministry
yeah uh so explain that a little bit
please so once a week we had a bunch of
people like uh
grocery stores like even like bakeries
and stuff like that they would donate a
bunch of food canned foods breads and
then each week my grandma would like
pack you a box and each family got a box
so each family that would come once a
week would get a whole box and get a
bunch of different food for like a week
or two
that's cool yeah so basically everyone
was getting fed by your grandma grandpa
they couldn't afford food that's because
when when you explained it to me
the thing that the only thing that
really upsets me
is your grandpa passed away and where
the [__] is everybody at that's what i
kind of that pisses me off yeah they
[__] fed the whole town for 35 years
gave people houses
never they just lived all they did was
live in their house
never took money like do you know what
i'm saying
they worked for free for for god
that's really what happened and i just
felt kind of like you know this funeral
i feel like there should be a million
people here what the [__] is going on i
felt the same thing that pissed me off
but
so many pastors showed up to her
grandpa's funeral oh yeah because he
worked with so many he was really
heavily like a part of that whole i
don't know what you would call it i
guess like a congregation
like he would travel to a bunch of
different hospitals and then in jails
too prisons that's what i was about to
get to we never got to go to the prisons
because we were kids but yeah we were
always going to the hospitals and
funerals he did so many funerals isn't
that crazy i feel like he's that yeah i
feel like that's why i'm kind of
like not numb but like i understand
funerals and everything like that like
the girl in my girl
oh
yes
very much so honestly like going to
funerals like we were those kids passing
out like the tissue bags yeah i'm fine
and the like obituaries like directing
people or like if somebody's kids
started crying during the service then
we would go and be like oh
take them for you don't worry
that's interesting but they help the
whole town everything i've
i'm trying to like ask the certain
questions to bring out the i don't want
to just directly say the story because
then the whole story's over tell me
about that time that god
you know what i'm saying
um
from
all right here it is this is how i feel
your grandma and grandpa were like
saving the [__] town
forever right they did and they all they
did was do good dude it was the weirdest
[__] because i've never met anybody
that's solely genuinely so good
so when i met them it was like this is
who raised you
holy [__] [__] this is awesome
that's what granny called him she
thought i was white until they died she
was so
she was so happy that you were white i
knew you would end up with a white guy
that's exactly what she told me i don't
understand not like an eraser
she was like i knew they knew you were
just going
to knew you would my grandma always said
i knew you would end up with a blonde
girl that's my grandma told me dolores
you know you're going to end up with a
blonde like a blonde girl i was blonde
for a minute so if your family would
have known what thomas's family was like
what would what would it oh that's fine
they wouldn't have judged oh no not at
all they [__] helped tweakers and
meth heads and heroines
yeah and my grandma she took in
i think well she was recognized one time
in the newspaper they took in over a
hundred different foster kids and then
my mom her brother
and my other aunt my uncle were also
adopted so there's four
not for the check
they've raised these kids from and
they're [__] in their 50s and 60s
but from ch
so from my perspective because i know
it's kind of hard for you to talk about
your grandma grab because it's just your
grand grandpa
that's that's amazing these movies where
you're like wow this man and this woman
really that's them i've never been more
shocked
it was so odd to me to see people that
were good like that that are just nice
they were just so [__] cool dude and
respectful as [__] and help anybody
that's what religion is supposed to be
they were straight up
so often like it was so weird for profit
and power and [__] you don't hear the
stories like that my grandpa always
preached about love
all the time like no matter what is
never about oh make sure you give an
offering today make sure you do this
like no not at all
whatsoever if you guys saw the dream
story time this is the grandpa we're
talking about same guy
oh yeah i forgot yeah that was a trip
when he told that story because he like
growing up we weren't i thought we
weren't allowed to but like we were
always just told not to ask him like
what happened whenever he was in the war
because he had yeah he had so like i
remember seeing his jacket and like all
the awards and stuff like that he had
and he never hung them up just because
he would tell us that like he didn't
want to think about it anymore
and that was weird the second you came
into the house like he just started
talking about it
okay background her grandpa had super
bad dimension when i met rosie um yeah
he was in the first beginning stages and
then it just got really bad for the
stories you guys told me he's just
his brain's gone yeah but he's there too
and he's a pastor it's just weird though
because sometimes yeah like how you said
like sometimes he was there and he was
present and like he knew everything that
was going on and then it was like a
light switch but it's weird cause he was
so big and his boys were so [__]
powerfully deep
that it's like it's like watching a lion
laid up in bed
like some big [__]
i don't know what it was about him he
had such a great pastor voice his voice
was like that perfect deepest i don't
know
very cool guy
from what i from what i met him sounds
like yeah super cool super cool but um
that's who rosie was raised by dude wow
it's so odd so rosie was the kid
so was your mom living there too or she
just like left you with them
oh the house is gigantic huge and then
they also own the house next to it and
there's an apartment built in the back
and then on the church there's a house
right there too so like my cousins lived
down the street we lived in the house
next to them and then
my grandma
she had custody over three of my cousins
so they lived in that house too
we have family in and out all the time
yeah their house is like hey arnold
building
like there's so many people living there
at all times if you think about it we're
all like that because we're all somewhat
different all of you and you're only
your own space yep girls live over here
this one's over here boys over here
so explain how you grew up how many
siblings did you grow up with
so technically there was six
there was at least like nine to 11 kids
in the house that they found
and then oh counting me my sister 12 to
13. then
you guys got it full court
and my girl
and my grandma would like every morning
that you got up
there was an aged sandwich
this is thomas's favorite story
preposterous [__] those things like we'd
get up every morning because
most of us were in high school the other
ones we went to school literally down
the street
but
every day before we went to school too
we have to read a chapter of the bible
so as you're coming down
you come downstairs or you come from
whatever house and all of our backyards
connected
that was the best part that was one of
my favorite things but um so then you
come downstairs
and there's an egg sandwich with your
lunch money next to you but each egg
sandwich is made
to how you exactly like it
like if you don't like mayonnaise and
cheese there's no mayonnaise that one's
not yours that one's not that's just
labeled no not even labels we all just
knew which one was ours yeah bro wow
it's it's like a movie what what movie
can we compare this to it's like the
kevin mcallister's house it's just like
that except it functions mm-hmm yeah
yeah i mean there's not some [__] uncle
little cheap [__] you that's it no no
so basically her grandma gets up by the
time you're out ready to go to school
your breakfast is [__] made exactly
how you like it your lunch is perfectly
ready done read your chapter of the
bible kids and then you can go to
[__] school that was the rule it's
structured oh by the way when you get
off you have to do six hours of bible
something something next door
and then come back home yep i will study
then come back and by the way this
sunday there's a lot more kids so we're
gonna need all of you to help chaperone
the little kids in in prayer school
that's exactly what we did yeah
literally
that's exactly how i
felt when she said it bible meeting
but then it's so different going to like
my dad's side of the family
because they're religious as well too
just not as heavy as my mom's parents so
when you met thomas were you like
did you change when you met thomas or
were you already that's a great question
i think
i think that could be answered by this
also what
were they strict were you allowed to
listen to stuff and watch stuff oh not
at all yeah
no i've gathered that much i wasn't
allowed to do anything she watched the
simpsons with me when we had cable
it was called the angel satellite
so we only got like christian channels
oh and everything was about jesus were
you allowed to listen to p.o.d
yes
all day all the time if i got any other
cd then i would have to like hide it and
listen to it in my room with like super
low
and like everybody knew like oh rosie's
listening to her music make sure you
don't see somebody go upstairs or go to
them
we all had each other's back but we knew
not to cross the line what would happen
if they were there [__] like like
what style of freakout would your
dad have for that no no your grandma
grant because her dad and mom are there
they're like my mom and dad they were
had jobs they were there but they
weren't on drugs but they weren't like
running the house and oh no no everyone
else is watching them my granny and pop
were the boss like we listened to them
like my mom and dad came home for dinner
and to put us to sleep oh okay
yeah yeah yeah
um wait what were you asking me were you
allowed to what was your punishment if
you got caught listening to [__] not
pod
it's like yard work
kitchen work you have to do a bunch what
if it was marilyn manson or a [__] oh
my god one time i called lacey
her cousin elise is like my sister she's
she's gay
she listens to wild [__] she's like he
does crazy hair and she's like my one
cousin that i was really really close to
growing up so she's like my big sister
she's like my sister dude yeah we grew
up in the same we grew the same weird
yeah but i remember this one time so
lacey was also i'm sorry lacey if you're
watching but she was also very [__]
spoiled she got everything she wanted
when she wanted to live in the back
apartment she got to live in the back
apartment by herself
and but that's when she got caught
listening to marilyn manson it really
was marilyn manson oh [__] that's why i
was like at least my because you're not
caught listening to that and i remember
i remember granny and pop came home
early because the chiropractor canceled
or something like that so they came home
way
faster than we thought and lacey was
bumping that music in the backyard did
your grandpa do um well pop couldn't do
anything why because he couldn't walk
remember he had
granny i've never seen granny run up the
stairs faster in my life she went up to
the thing the apartment has the second
story by the way
this is all on their property
just praying the [__] drugs away bro
it's crazy like a shield they had a
force field of all the meth around the
central valley stay out of here
it's crazy
[Music]
it's true you had a little a shield
see i don't ever think it's like sounds
wild because i mean that's just we're
the addicts all doing drugs and stealing
from them taking advantage of them all
the time and [__] like was that going on
yeah family members though sometimes but
they were mostly yeah our family members
damn so my grandma had custody over
almost like six of my cousins just
because two of their moms were heavily
on drugs growing up and they were mainly
the ones that would
i mean
they would but i mean i never i just
heard the stories i never seen so they
grew up all religious and [__] just the
same but they ended up on strong being
strong her mom and her uncle art they're
like in their 50s right they're so
scared so they they're squares which are
good because they grew up in the church
playing the piano so did their sisters
which is their cousin's moms but once
they got out they're like yo motley crue
[__] lines yeah [__] those are my
mom's cousins
nieces oh i'm sorry i'm sorry i meant
that i meant the way you guys lived
together is the way you live with their
kids yeah that's what i meant like
they're you that's why i said siblings
but they're not really your siblings so
to answer my question you were very
different when you met thomas then if he
put you on to the [__] simpsons in
the whole world okay so yes and no no
i was pretty much myself still okay
so i kind of grew up sorry you grew up
i grew up very heavily in the church you
guessed it very square like i would this
is where he's what he's asking this week
oh i would say maybe around 14.
so i was 14 when i first tried smoked
wheat now this is my homie and i feel
like ever since the one that was all
strung out and in the [__] house
this is my other friend from like down
the street
but um
i feel like
well the first time i ever smoked weed i
cried after because i thought i was
going to go to hell because all i kept
hearing was my grandma telling me like
that's what happens to you i would want
to say like maybe 16
16 i kind of like broke away from it not
so much broke away from it like i still
have a lot of respect for it but it's
just that's not realized it wasn't for
you yeah you got to be your [__]
strong will to stand up for yourself in
that situation
so rosie went him or said hi we're
religious that's yeah that's in a lot of
things
just
merced [__] it happened
oh yeah we have a thing rosie and i
if you guys please don't get offended
rosie and i
what do you refer to most women as oh
[__]
it's just all this [__] it's not like
oh this dude some guy some jig some
chicks some guys some girls
i was talking about that one man you
know the [__] [__] the dumb one i'm
not being offensive we say it back and
forth so [__] hard that it's just
second nature it's like the word the
we forget something i forget in public
when i'm in public
i'm like all this [__] is taking
forever
sorry it's not just me and you because
that's how we communicate and talk
oh this [__] [__] oh this [__]
and i call dudes [__] too when they're
acting like a [__] [__]
yeah we broke this down last episode
okay yeah but this is how rosie and i
talk so
dumb [__] [__] merced [__] [__] it
went through your face when rosie came
to merced she got she succumbed to
merced bed [__] which is
you know normal normal stuff but he's
smoking still living at home doing all
this [__] though yes but then again i
didn't live in planada anymore my family
moved just her mom and dad because my
mom and dad and me and my sister so no
more in the church why did they do that
honestly i think because my dad was just
tired of living around them because he's
not i mean he grew up super religious
and everything but he's not like that
like once you guys grew up more like me
yeah he moved like he was living on his
own by the time he was like 14 15. like
by on like his main choice like he
decided to do that because he didn't
want to live with his dad anymore
it's just
yeah and then after that he just wanted
to break away and then that's when it
all happened
yeah so that's it but they kept all the
values and all that oh yeah i still had
to go to church every sunday
every sunday until i was 18. yeah but
it's not every day like that like well
you're not working there every day
you're not doing all that crazy [__]
ever so you were happy when you moved
out oh i was so stuck
i played a lot of sports too so once i
started playing sports then i didn't
have to do as much church stuff so rosie
moon tumor said
or said a bit [__]
and then to answer your questions would
she all hold
did you move to this name did you move
to the hood of merced or just like a
normal part oh no cool spots yeah i
lived in i guess you would say the good
side of the mercedes yeah even the hood
spotters of merced don't look [__] up
no it's the people that [__] live in
there yeah that that's interesting the
grimy [__] that that's a big difference
on the west coast like you could be deep
in the [__] hood and really not even
in some
spots like oh this kind of looks like a
normal [__] neighborhood yeah yeah
it's just the people that live there
yeah so
to answer your question fully when you
move to merced she's already wrote she's
already doing her thing yeah yeah so
it's not like i met her and [__] like
here's we uh-huh no
no [__] no no homer simpson she's the
one with tattoos and [__] she looks like
you i know you got weight nice okay you
know that makes sense yeah yeah no
none of that mm-hmm so that long but how
wait so how old were you when you met
thomas
well i knew of you what senior year i
don't remember i think so because you
weren't third our junior year and i had
cap at junior i was but i was also
not over there
i thought you had left
no sophomore year oh okay
well i remember seeing him a lot senior
year
uh-huh were you already a street racer
at that point
no i was becoming one oh [__] okay
genesis that was after high school yeah
oh okay
so that was one of my next ones is why
don't you have your license until
you just recently get your license back
because
i was kind of dating a guy at the time
he was really into cars and i had a
really dope honda and he kind of souped
it up
and then he was into street racing all
his friends were too and then that's
kind of how we got into it and then i
just loved it it was so much fun
so you had this souped-up [__] honda
but your parents didn't realize you were
like how'd they were they like oh my god
loves cars oh the fact that
the car was getting worked on and it was
getting better it was like exciting for
him so you were able to like listen to
music and live your life a little bit
after you moved out yeah after
after we left planada things got a lot
easier my parents really aren't that
straight especially when my grandma's
not there
to watch my mom or kind of tell her like
yo this isn't right we shouldn't be
doing this
yeah
well [__] i mean that when you told me
that i'm like
what do you mean you're a street racer
i went to a few sideshows you'd go to
sideshows in the bay area a lot
and then
this one time i was at a race and we got
caught and
they took a bunch of pictures of my
tattoos and i had a court date that i
had to go into
and then
i also got like six tickets wait you got
caught because like they [__] like
identified you by your tattoos no they
knew the street race was going on so the
cops showed up to the street race oh
yeah and so we all got arrested oops
sorry we tried to like you know drive
yeah i would imagine that we still got
caught we got pulled over
names taken down and everything
and then i also had other speeding
tickets because i went to school out of
town so i would be driving fast all the
time
so then
getting caught plus my speeding tickets
with the court date
the judge pretty much was
i don't even remember exactly
i remember i got
a huge fine i had to do community
service and they suspended my license
until i was 25.
i was 19. damn
when i first got with april i was taking
her back and forth the [__] court
dates and [__] also
yeah no this is pretty pretty me oh yeah
okay way before time
yeah i was only 19. she had no license
at all until
we lived in l.a
and they just like cleared my record
nice yeah they just kind of forgot about
it
it just went away that's cool i mean
chet you only got caught for one street
racing incident i mean
well she got like [__] six speeding
tickets going fast as [__] in a month i
was late well because my school was like
45 minutes away and you know i was 18
and dumb at the time so i didn't
i wasn't very responsible so most of the
time i would just be like [__] i got 30
minutes to make it to class all right
and i would just step on it the whole
entire way she had the souped up little
honda the super soup to honda it was a
lightweight honda accord it was fast
ones yeah we didn't have that whole
[__] street racer honda culture and
[__] boss that's different like when
you [__] with the hondas and [__] that's
a whole different type of
culture yeah when you [__] with the
street cars like that it's more like oh
you guys got pistols fine i don't want
to be in this neighborhood i want to be
at your street race but when it's when
it's different [__] like
the monty's and stuff like that oh it's
all the older men coming out with their
wives and [__] let's go have fun like
that's cool no one's gonna fight they
might have like a drunken beer fight
okay
but that kind of street ratio merced at
that time was dangerous oh yeah it was
just dangerous i'm cool
everybody was doing it too like from
merced up to the bay area i felt damn
yeah so that's why i shouldn't have a
license for so long but i haven't now
yeah i don't drive fast anymore even
when we have the bend it kind of scares
me now because
[Music]
now when i think about it it's like i
cannot believe i was going that fast i
cannot believe it
this car is different you can go 130 and
go oh my [__] god i was going 75.
and it's i don't call that danger i
would not go that fast either i don't
even think i've hit 100 in this you
shouldn't i don't it's not worth it yeah
it's like oh i don't need to get
anywhere that fast
yeah i've been in too many accidents i
never drive [__] fast
i could barely drive there was a stretch
where i didn't want to drive on the
[__] freeways
i get like that sometimes around here
yeah it's too much
yeah well rosie you've been in hell
accidents
rosie was in a really bad one dude with
her cousin lacy my cousin lacey and
i mean she was my friend at the time we
just don't talk anymore
this is lina
how old was i
14 no 15.
my cousin just got this really dope ass
honda civic and uh
she was picking me up well actually i
did school that day i don't know if i
told you that i did school that day we
went to merced
got food
came back and we picked up one of my
friends and then on our way to the high
school because there's another town it's
like 10 miles away called legrand and
that's where i went to high school at
um we're on our way but instead of
taking the main road we took the back
roads i don't know why we did that but
we did and then
my cousin i don't know why but she was
just we're just messing around that day
so she's driving in her car and we're
going side to side and she's kind of
going out through each lane and then she
starts going faster and then that's
whenever she catches the dirt and the
whole entire car just flips and there's
just fields around us like there's
orchards
orchards around trees but
thankfully
we flipped in a field that had no trees
so and then our car also flipped like
forward not sideways like it didn't
tumble
and then i remember
i remember being in the car and seeing
the dirt in the sky and then it felt
like somebody
grabbed me and pulled me out of the car
but then i also hear window breaking and
i can hear like my friend screaming
because my friend is in the back
me and my cousin me and my friend got
ejected from the car
and then my cousin was still in the car
and somehow she was able to stop
somebody
and then somebody stopped over for us
and then
i remember getting up but i couldn't
really walk and like something was wrong
with like my hip that's all i really
remember
and then i remember waking up in the
hospital you went through the glass yeah
when i see the window now that i went
through it's just it doesn't make any
sense i showed you right at the picture
i haven't never seen the pictures i
gotta find it so what were your injuries
i had like a cracked hit fractured hit
i had a bunch of bruising uh cracked
ribs bruised ribs
and then my friend she kind of got the
worst of it though because when she fell
out of the car well got ejected she went
through the back window because she
didn't have her seatbelt on and we
didn't know that
but
i guess whenever she got ejected from
the car when she landed she landed on
her feet so she broke which ones are
these calls oh she broke the [__]
femurs
broke them backwards because she when
she got ejected she landed the
eyes what are the odds she gets ejected
from a car lands on her feet but the
pressure just snaps both her legs back i
just yeah
i remember waking up and asking like
where she was at and like they had to
tell me what happened oh
yeah so you got up and then probably
just passed out in shock yeah i don't
remember i just remember waking up ugh
i'd be so heated lacie was fine huh lucy
was fine she got like a split eyebrow
she like kind of bruised her clavicle or
something from hitting the steering
wheel and that was it isn't that crazy
just [__] around so be careful yeah
we always say please drive safe don't
[__] around because that was nothing you
guys were doing nothing and just
started playing with the [__] wheel
yeah flipping dude and the next day i
was supposed to take my driving test oh
god
oh i don't think you told me that yeah
the next day i was supposed to take my
driving test the behind the wheel
because my dad had just taken me to go
do the written test and everything and
then i ended up waiting until i was 18
to get my license
it was too much i just didn't want to
drive anymore after that were you into
fast and furious
oh 100
[Laughter]
i remember after i see that i was
[__] peeling out in the [__]
station wagon and [__] i feel like that
enticed my
speeding
yeah i know
i know i've always told drugs though so
i was never speeding and doing crazy
[__] i grew up around cars so like going
fast little background her dad
which year was it that he swept
california
2019 before the pandemic yeah he swept
uh every [__] show in california
first place
because he he builds low riders that's
his [__] but now he built his own now he
builds his own and he [__] swept
california with it every con or every
show he entered he at least plays first
or second damn that crazy bro they wrote
about what magazine i think it's impalas
and paula's magazine about like johnny
reese yeah it's really cool his truck
now
is well he always tries to buy the
bonnie but i'm never going to [__]
sell it to you sorry forever sorry dad
never going to happen um
but yeah that's rosie's racing life the
crazy [__] she used to do
and uh
real quick let's touch on it how what
time are we at
uh i mean we're at 40.
oh damn we're doing this for this yeah
it's been a minute okay so you're doing
fine i did good
real quick
when we did mushrooms at
the push trees house okay
what happened when you were staring at
the wall just a quick touch on me rosie
by the way when i take seven grams of
mushrooms everything i do we split
she takes seven i take seven she's like
see what's going on like we don't all
drugs we take the same amount
i try to keep up yeah i take this i
didn't realize that rosie does every the
same thing not alcohol not alcohol
anymore
not anymore
as we got older like she just can't
handle as much liquor as i can anymore i
guess you could fit a side question just
because you're such good friends with
april what kind of drunk person are you
are you just like the same person or the
violent version of yourself
okay loud all right i'm just loved
april's confrontational as [__] oh
oh no well see maybe that's not good for
me and april to be around each other no
i'll get hyped i'll be like oh yeah why
is april mad yeah
she starts
i just smoke a lot more weed i take huge
dabs when i'm drunk i'm the perfect
drunk person i never get [__] violent
yeah nothing i've always got my
composure and i'm just like yo you guys
will take more dabs take bigger ribs no
you just laugh a lot but i'm just saying
nothing else change i just go i just get
balls here and go i bet you i could kill
that whole [__] thing and [__] that's
what happens like my fear goes away like
i don't want to sit there and cough and
maybe throw up no he doesn't care i
don't care when i'm drunk i'll just
[__] flex this [__] out yep yeah i do
it's very odd how many times do i do
that all for nothing
a lot a lot like you'll flex that [__]
out
oh sorry what happened when you look at
the wall with the mushrooms when we took
all those [__] mushrooms to push
tree's house the one in our bedroom yes
the one okay when we moved in the push
tree's house originally remember the
scary art on the wall it was scary but
it was amazing i forgot about that until
recently
we moved in to our push trees house we
posted it do we never showed you in the
kitchen there's a realistic gigantic as
big as this table
picture of a realistic ladybug
smoking a big-ass [__] cigarette
joint i say joint
it's holding on to clear when you go
when we moved in like on the wall on the
wall in the kitchen it stayed i wanted
to keep it when we left we wanted to cut
it out but it was it's a huge ladybug
it was the house from 1920. i can't
remember what some type of painted on
the wall
is bigger than this tree times to this
tree yeah
in the kitchen right and then
in the back side bedroom was this weird
like fat face have you ever seen the
gorillas uh the gorillas video i gotta
tell you
no no it's the
the [__] yes it's just there it's the
the white guy's head and he's [__]
singing the chorus it's that guy's face
it's like with like all the smoke and
bubbles and color and it looked like an
acid trip
on our wall a fish on the head it was a
fish on the head rosie wow we got a it
was a fisherman it was a guy with like
big old like directions like he had
scales coming out of his head like a
fish like a koi fish but a red one
whoa
it just like came back you're right it
just hit me right now the corner of the
room because now i remember looking at
it like oh no
so oh what happened
when we were sitting in my bed just
tripping
and then what happened when you looked
at the wall my granny came out of the
picture
oh [__] wait out of the
out of the before she passed away her
grandma's still alive oh my god granny
was still alive at that point and she
knew what i was doing oh she started
haunting you preemptively
god damn it was so scary that was like
the trippiest mushroom trip i've ever
what'd she tell you
i don't know
i know what you said what i know what
you're doing these drugs are bad you can
go to hell for doing these drugs i just
remember she knew what i was doing and
she was mad at me she told me as it was
happening stop look at the [__] wall
and then we watched the flintstones and
then we watched some footsteps damn she
was in your subconscious she was so mad
at me like her face came out of the
clouds and everything the good
flintstones john goodman flintstones by
the way guys part one not two that was a
trip oh yeah every time i like think of
a mushroom trip that went weird that's
that's the one you know it's oddly
enough i know my mom's gonna watch this
that's the night i started talking to my
mom that's the night we called your mom
when i was started dating rosie for the
first year and a half and three years
before i did not talk to my mom what so
[__] ever
yeah i told remember that during the
episode like i got to put a kill in your
ass one time for a few seconds and then
i snapped back into earth i wish you
could have seen rocco's face
yeah because some [__] happened with my
mom we talked about it i don't know she
doesn't want me to [__] talk about it
but some [__] happening i'm in the
[__] right but we're fine now
and everybody agrees
anyway uh some [__] happened where i was
like [__] i'll [__] take your life
it was crazy i'm sorry i'm sorry i'm
sorry i'm sorry i know you guys like you
told me what a piece of [__] it's
different all right my little brother's
like my son
as a kid like so don't try to [__] do
it you know what i mean anyway we'll
leave it at that
did i talk to my mom for years i caught
i [__] had like a spark in my head
and i called my mom and i [__]
squashed it while i'm tripping hard as
[__] she's sitting across from the table
and she's like
are you guys okay this is the first time
she's ever talked to rosie because
because i have christmas christmas time
thanksgiving i do not talk to my mom we
sit in the same [__] room in
christmas and i just do this
john's it's john cena i don't see her
ass she's invisible i do not speak to
her don't even acknowledge that she's in
the room i don't [__] with her yeah like
i got to that point i'm like i can't i
can't even [__] nope and i just knew
her as the dope nail lady i was like yes
your mom is adultery so i've been dating
rosie she's living with me we've been
living together for a [__] almost a
year this is my
this is rosie
and then i'm like yo you're about to
talk to my mom
first time insurance on [__]
mushrooms in person in person because i
don't [__] with her i don't should come
to my [__] house but hold on hold on
now you guys were just in the room
looking at the [__] no i called my
mom and called to [__]
i had this weird spark in my head of
like yo
just squash [__] some people are [__]
psychotic
and that's just cool now but back
remember i said back we did not get
along yeah no this is during the time
and this is the first time rosie ever
had a conversation or where she was
sitting you were right here i was right
here i'm almost straight across my mom
was straight across and she's looking
she sits down i talked to my mom outside
we squashed it i'm like come in
come meet my [__] girlfriend
does she know you guys are tripping
balls
she sits there and goes
what's wrong with you guys
and i look here and i go i'm so [__]
up on mushrooms right now man she goes
that's why they called me i go yeah i
had a thing in my head that goes yeah
you need to squash that's why you're
here harvard can you be friends now and
then she's like
you guys are that [__] up and i looked
at rosie you know she ate as much as i
did is she mad at you too or did she
understand why you're so mad at
her oh
i don't know oh she wished she could
take it back
so it wasn't like she was mad at you
yeah she oh she wasn't mad at me yeah
she had no [__] reason to be mad like
around that christmas time like i
remember like when we were around her
and they still weren't talking she would
say hi to him but she's mad stubborn bro
oh yeah she's so stubborn but no no
if i'm wrong i'm wrong i'll say i'll
apologize right away i wasn't wrong yeah
i wasn't wrong at all
but
but we were we were
there and we had a conversation for like
four hours and i was on
mushrooms
i'm sitting there looking at my mom and
you guys are talking like i don't even
remember i have no idea what we talked
about i was so gone so [__] up
so gone i just remember trying like
thinking about it now it's like i just
remember thinking compose yourself
compose yourself get it together
i was like holy [__]
this [__] mom's here yeah it's our
first time ever like we're talking
because i was around pepper and john all
the time we were there like at least
once a week having dinner yeah when i
when i first started dating rosie me and
my uncle john were chilling every day
yeah john was john was like the first
person i met besides sharing
did he live next door to your mom at
that time no uh they lived on 24th
street and me and her live on 27th
street at the post trees house
and uh i was just at john and pepper's
all days when little cousin memphis was
like seven or eight
so yeah now he's like six six bro he's a
gigantic [__] kid
and uh i mean obviously uncle john's
gone now but
i was with him every [__] day we'll
say it briefly but one time rosie's
[__] sister got shot in the [__]
head it was a crazy ass experience i was
with john we were playing video games
and i just got the call
from you and i just heard screaming and
you like kind of said what you said i
went
what we were dating for three weeks
holy crap we weren't even living with me
yet no
i was still at the duplex yep
she wasn't even living in my we she
moved in a [__] month because i went
nope you're going to live with me
forever yeah that's how we're doing
that's exactly what we did today but no
this is this is perfect and then she
didn't even live with me yet mm-hmm but
i remember i just went ah
[__] started running john so what the
[__] i know he was like i got god what
do we need to do i know my uncle's what
he was thinking i'm like rosie such a
[__] shout out
and i [__] smashed i pulled pieces of
[__] moves i felt so horrible driving
i got there before they did and i was on
the opposite side of town i was closer
to that i got there before her [__]
dad did too
goddamn i'm a pizza delivery driver bro
i know every [__] road
and i remember i hit 120 on [__] m
oh my god
at 120 on m
street merced
i felt like a piece of [__] and then
when i passed somebody like this on
[__] yosemite his wife stuck out his
head i just heard you [__] piece of
[__] and i just all everything piece of
[__] i'm sorry and i mean no i even did
i went i'm sorry i even screamed i'm
sorry as i was on the shoulder passing
her on yosemite to the hospital i went
because i was going so fast i slowed
down to like 50 went oh [__]
and when i got there i was just like no
i have to be here and when i got there
i'm like
forrest gump before
where are you that's all i remember
thinking like
you guys all drive fast
where the [__] how are you
and then i realized like oh yeah but my
whole family also truck drivers and
drivers
that's where i get it from yeah i used
to do a little thing side note where i
would try to drive to santa cruz without
touching the wheel
there's only five turns from my house so
many times i've successfully done it but
i touched it once
rosie's a witness to all the great
things i've done
oh my greatness so there's only five
turns to get santa cruz true all right
you take a street you hit our [__]
side freeway hit 140 that's two turns
all the way to pacheco off another turn
watsonville my sister's [__] exit in
santa cruz that's it it's five turns oh
my gosh it really is where did i touch
the wheel when i got to santa cruz on my
sister's street because i couldn't get
into a driveway i was so heated like i
made it all the way
i was just trying to think of the
driveway yeah it was super sharp yeah so
i would drive with my knee and we'd
smoke blunts and joints and bowls that's
when i didn't know how to roll joints so
he would have to wait
and i'd just roll all the weed and we
just talk and just who needs a tesla
yeah no i did because it was the thing
with my friends i used to do forehead
driving
i used to do i wasn't there for that
yeah i used to do i did this thing
warhead driving okay when i first oh god
i used to [__] grab the wheel and
drive like how do you see the road look
straight straight
i knew him i should do that yeah you
should do it with my friend deuce and
michael logan
and they because i'm such a good driver
bro i'd be like i'm [__] bored
and we'd be doing that [__] around town
right and i would do knee driving and
i've i've made u-turns with the with no
tans what you do is you put your right
thigh knee towards your handle touch the
wheel and then like open your hip and
you can flip your entire car around i've
been there she's been there so i used to
do i'd be sitting up in my chair it was
so off topic
sorry
it's fine but someone's here to like
you're a live [__] like no i'm not he
has done it i've seen it
well before i met her i stopped forehead
driving forever though i was with my
friend deuce yeah and i was turning and
i hit [__] curb straight on
and it hurt my face so
bad bro cause i'm sitting here doing
this and i couldn't get the turn so as i
did it i went boom and i smashed my [__]
held the wheel steve ocean juice is just
dawn
[Laughter]
green dodge and tripping i can see you
induced now bam smackdown let's get out
of it right by my grandpa's the sixth or
seventh in us
i was almost home and took the turn god
cracked the [__] out of my face i never
knew how many people saw you nobody no
no
but yeah she's been there for that i do
i'm not no more though no you don't do
that i haven't done it in a long time
but
no yeah no hands driving is was so fun
it was a good show so fun i stopped
when we started driving a lot of packs i
stopped
that's really when it slowed down as i
was about to ask you when did you stop i
just stopped one day because remember i
i forget about phases in life remember
we talked about earlier there's phases
in life do you remember when we first
started dating i would just scream songs
at the top of my lungs as loud as i
could out of [__] nowhere it's more
mellow now but yeah and then i forgot i
used to do that
and it was fun yeah
yeah
we talked about this the other day
that's why when justin boyd comes in
town it's coming back
it's coming back
i'm bringing it back so um it's okay
your grandma yelled at you don't do
drugs oh so hold on were you thinking
about her at all prior to her actually
starting to come out of the [__]
painting
what a rant i'm so
[Laughter]
now i understand why these rants start
and like how they do you see what i'm
saying now yeah
it just blossoms it branches off a tree
i don't remember thinking about her
no because i feel like when i was at
that age like i didn't
not that i didn't have any remorse but
it's just not something that i thought
about we're like walking around feeling
guilty to the lord and [__] over here
living in your life also you got to
remember
rosie's the one doing crazy [__] getting
[__] up going to shows getting all
these tattoos doing crazy [__] i'm doing
wild stuff and selling halloween but i
am the most chill laid back under the
cover perfect low-key guy you can meet i
used to go to warehouse shows in the bay
area by myself sometimes mm-hmm
she tells me about they wake up in
frisco on a beach is some crazy [__]
there's been plenty of times with me and
my friends just leave we'd hop on a bus
or just drive there and be like oh
we don't know we're just going to get
[__] up and then we'll wake up and i'm
on a beach and we'll just walk back to
the car wherever we parked it up i
always had too much responsibility to
ever do that i wish i could have
now that i think about it i was [__]
i can't believe me and monica would do
you guys [__] killed oh 100 yeah for
sure for sure yeah so many times but i'm
saying i've never had like i told rosie
my number one thing i ever want to do is
just fall asleep outside it's amazing
i've never been able to fall asleep like
you know you see you ever like sit on
the grass you're like yo i could fall
asleep out here there's a breeze i'm
under a tree someone's gonna stab me i
can't fall asleep bro when i was on the
beach
no i made myself lay on the beach and
just look up in the [__] clouds and
just it's too vulnerable to me i feel
like someone can come up and stomp me
right now and i wouldn't know
sure
so i wish i could go to the beach and
just be carefree but i can't because i
have a [__] fear of like
humans doing crazy [__] i see people
sleep in the park i'm like yo bums
[__] bum's got the life sometimes man
you gotta worry about [__] gonna be
nowhere i say this all the time like
you're gonna be nowhere you don't have
those
[__] you
but also now let's do your [__] again
i'm not doing that i'd rather be
stressed
but anyway man i like when i used to get
up for school i'm like my dog wait [__]
i'm gonna do [__] i'm tired [__] you a
dog yeah dog janice like me yeah i'm
sleeping and [__] i'm so excited i talk
[__] to the animals all the
i time getting ready for my wrestling
tournament mariposa i remember putting
on my socks going
it's so [__] you know it's five it's
five
and then i that's where i won that first
place and i went [__] get up early all
the time
and then i never won again that was the
only time i won
um off topic completely my next question
what would you be doing where would you
be if we never met
some butterfly effect [__]
well before
we started dating remember i was trying
to get a job at the resorts in colorado
you were about to move away yeah i
remember that now and you said you were
gonna get a neck tattoo and i was like
oh yeah and you told me ill and i got
really sad and mad at you or anything
she did she got offended i went oh don't
do that i was gonna hear once i'm
oh
now the neck tattoos are bad but the one
you were saying was like i don't oh yeah
when i think about it now i'm like that
would have been terrible
i wanted to get one just to make sure
i'd never have a [__] job
the color of your skin
you're always qualified
i'm sorry dude you're tall white guy
with blue eyes
you killed my marty
you got this bro you're you're annie
you're in i couldn't get a job with the
[__] without the [__] neck tattoo
that's buffalo though
come anywhere else there's no
opportunities like mercedes true it's
like this is a black hole just like
merced but yeah you love that place
i do
that's nice i like i like when people
like where they're from even i love it i
love it even though it's full of trash i
[__] love that place and i always
said before i met you
what's the one thing i'm gonna do when
i'm older become mere merced
i've been saying this about 16 years old
this is before yeah since before we
started dating you would always tell me
that too i'll be the merry merced one
day just so i can do what
is it
the outlaw bicycling
outlaw cyclist in the road get the [__]
out of my way
get the [__] out of my way one thing
that one time it's multiple times no
i
bro get the [__] out the street
get out of the way
you act like you could eat the whole
road eat a [__] dick that's why that
megaphone's in the warehouse she bought
that for me we first started dating
because i used to yell at cyclists nice
and santa cruz out my window get the
[__] out it's like here's a megaphone
and i started hitting them with the
[__] out the way and i made sure it had
like the little woo woo yeah nice yeah
[Music]
yeah and i can just do it like that get
the [__] out of the way i love that it
was great [__] cycling that was such a
great idea we need to vlog you just
doing that i'm a very angry person when
it comes to things i hate uh-huh i i
guess i'm i'm
[Music]
i get very angry yeah
at people that are dumb
just be considerate get the [__] out the
way like yo there's a whole car if i hit
you
i go to prison yeah
you die i have prison sentence get the
[__] out the way i'm trying to drive
[__] freedom right now yeah bro it's
serious the tour de france came to
merced one time and then everybody
became a cyclist and that's why this
happened to me just ruined merced you
know racist like oh they let all the
mexicans in town and that's why i
[__] hate mexicans i feel about that
that's how i feel about psychos the
[__] tour de france came to town they
let them all in i remember they blocked
off the road in the middle of the
[__] town dude they blocked off all
the bear crews
i [__] with cyclists that go in the bike
lane i really appreciate that
that's all
other than that
thank you the big groups oh they all go
sideways so they can talk to each other
but they eat up a lane of traffic
[__] you and all the cyclists only came
to me in ed's so i had to talk to these
guys
that was the spot they all came in i'll
drink [__] beer going towards the
mountains because remember they go they
take all their mouths i hated driving
out towards the mountains and like
you're going around the hill and like oh
[__] cyclists in the middle of the road
that's where i the only time i found
myself hating [__] cyclists is going
up to big sur scary you're on the edge
of a mountain and you got some [__]
fool just on his [__] bike and it's
barely big enough for the two cars going
up the edge of the mountain it's just
scary it's like yo i want to go home not
prison if i accidentally hurt you yeah i
would not want to hurt you get the [__]
out the streets for cars you know so off
topic
where would you be doing
butterfly effect
well i was trying to get a job in
colorado at the resorts
okay uh my aunt was like it's a great
job we know people out there who hook
you up and then
i don't um you're working at rts
rts you're working at rts right yeah the
audit company yeah you know when you see
people in the stores they're doing that
on the pad and they're looking at all
the items doing all the skew numbers
they do that do the audit that's what
she did when we first started dating
that's what she was doing i loved it it
was so much fun but your shifts sucked
it was so actually you had to work at
like [__] 12 to 8 in the morning
or go to work at nine and get off at six
i'm just stupid bro and then i had to
travel because i traveled up and down
the san joaquin valley
it was fun though i had a hell of fun
doing it i was doing that and then i
also i mean i still went to nursing
school and i did all that and that's
something that i wanted to do
i think i probably would have kept on
going with that
and i probably would have been stuck
back living in merced
i mean it's nothing nothing bad but i
would probably be living there you know
doing my family stuff every sunday
which isn't bad i still miss it but
yeah that's what i would probably be
doing i probably have kids by now for
sure
yeah i'm glad we went this way instead
of that crazy
i think about it all the time too i'm
like damn my life would be so different
i think out of all my friends now
growing up through high school i'm the
only one who doesn't have kids yet um
you guys are wildly responsible for not
having kids
bro i'm trying to get dumb rich i just
like to own a house dumb rich and buy
everyone buy everyone else at how
because the only thing keeping us from
buying a house is trying to buy other
people's stuff too yeah like i'm trying
like oh okay
we we're
if we saved our money we'd be done we'd
be good but we're trying to help this
and trying to help this
you know family
yeah i mean i'm just grateful that we
have that opportunity yeah that's the
whole point like oh i i'm able to help i
don't mind living in an apartment if we
have if we can if i could still help
yeah that's the whole point but we'll
eventually get there you know
yeah but that's the whole point we're
super responsible because we who else is
going to be for us
could see because
push trees could die in five seconds if
we don't do anything oh a hundred
percent it could be over yeah of course
i stopped doing videos for [__] a
year and like oh it's gone yeah it'd be
a whole different life a whole different
life which is fine it's cool
way less responsibility
which is like a
holy [__] i can breathe
okay because we're very busy like you
know that
and it's just
there's just so many so many businesses
going on so much stuff happening that
yeah
yeah we're we're i like it i love it i
love it i would not want to be born
yeah i was gonna say we're non-stop busy
we always have something going on always
that's cool yeah
um my last piece we're at 59.
now 104. 105.
you're real close
yeah artist
[__] alpha brain alpha brain i did
not take that today but
on it here we go
i'm sorry i'm like high
that's really [__] me up yeah i'm just
just let me put a little caveat on that
last one since we spoke last i've had a
[__] mushroom trip thank you
a mushroom trip
yeah did we not tell you no okay
i was mushroom defective marty has
three times disney nothing happens mario
calls me the day and says this yeah the
half of one of those chocolate buyers is
the magic [__] tell us what'd you do
marty
tell everybody i didn't plan it out
right at all i did this [__] completely
[__] wrong to begin with because
i didn't think it was gonna hit me
i was like all right so i worked all day
i forget what day it was but like i was
editing all day
just like going about my day and then
april like took the kids somewhere and
i'm like i'm gonna eat all right you
were in our house
one of our we have two living rooms one
of the living rooms was completely full
of our [__] because we got the garage
redone so all the [__] from the garage
got put into the living room literally
all of our things completely from the
floor to ceiling cupboard with our [__]
so
i had to like move all that into the
garage and then like we had just you
know
clean the whole house i had a whole
night's worth of [__] to do and i knew
that she was leaving i was going to get
it all done before she got home so i was
like i'll eat one of this little bit of
chocolate maybe give me a little
pick-me-up while i'm doing all this [__]
because i i've never saw mushrooms when
i just wake me up ever i've never been
on mushrooms so i didn't [__] know i
was popping those little pills nothing's
happening very good point i was popping
a little bit they're not a sativa yeah
like that's how i was thinking about it
like i don't [__] know you know but
then the fans made a good point that
like because i was trying it and then i
was trying to like dip my toe in too
much and then you build up a tolerance
yeah quickly apparently
this wasn't was enough yeah i just like
took like half the [__] chocolate bar
basically maybe like four or five four
blocks off it right down the hatch
didn't even really think about it
but then i started [__] tripping
so i just like i was just starting to
[__] feel weird and i'm like okay all
right it's working finally i've been
[__] asking for this [__] now [__]
all right so i just lay down on the
couch thank god there was nobody there
because
for the first hour to an hour and a half
i remember thinking like there's no way
i could talk right now
any time i tried to even formulate a
[__] word i just started giggling
that was just there's no way the
uncontrollable giggles are a very real
thing yeah there was no way i could talk
almost like you throw up because you
can't catch a breath because you're
[__] laughing i've had that i got the
giggles so hard at martin's friend
yes yes that's what marty caught sorry
no that that's exactly what happened it
was terrible yeah
i could think like i was i was aware of
what was going on so i just kind of laid
down on the couch and then i started
going through waves of like when i would
close my eyes i would start like [__]
oh no like you know it was just so
random i don't even remember what i was
seeing it was very random and very just
like i don't want to say like anime but
just kind of all over the place and then
i'd open my eyes and that the
windows were kind of like getting in
smaller a little bit and [__] and i'm
kind of just laughing and giggling and
then i remember i'd be like
close my eyes again and kind of go back
into it
and i did that probably 10 times
but the whole time i'm also thinking
like bro you gotta [__] clean the
whole house
so i really didn't relax
i didn't relax you could have got there
i think and then after about maybe an
hour i like got up and i you know i
don't know the whole house [__] i came
too the whole house was clean
and a whole house i got all the [__]
done by the time april got back i didn't
even tell her that i had tripped out
till the next day just cause i didn't
how long did it last for you
it was lasting at some level the whole
time she was gone so maybe like four
hours but it was that first hour
where i was like i remember i looked at
my phone
and i'm like oh i can't step back
does that feel weird in your hand not so
much
but i was like oh yeah there was i was
joints
feel it flat one of my mushrooms i roll
them like this because i can't grip it i
feel like there's no edges yeah
i didn't have that it reminded me of the
first times i really got high off weed
in that it's like oh i feel like my legs
i feel that my arms tingles yeah tingles
but it was way stronger not it wasn't
like a little bit of tingles it was like
full [__] tingle and
going on across the board
but it was it was like it was like early
weed high just stronger and more intense
but it was i guess that's kind of but i
had the sense of like oh i've been here
before and i've [__] been here before
so don't you keep that mentality you're
gonna not freak out as long as you
remember like i'm at home dude it's just
my brain aware of
that so you have to keep like but i do
feel like i barely just [__]
scratched the surface
it gets intense yeah
yeah yeah so i'm gonna have to re-up on
those [__] chocolate bars and
figure it out i got you
i'll get more we're not no we're riding
from oakland legally
you can't do that hey man that's what i
said yeah no magical fairy trapped these
[__] things off i don't know where
they came from this [__] was just there
when we bought the house they grow from
the ground in the packaging it's crazy
it's [__] badass
um
okay
one more thing yeah
sorry no no by the way because i needed
that the mushrooms yeah i would say one
more thing you need to do
is eat a [__] load of mushrooms and go
in the dark like i told you yeah i was
in the dark that was the thing though i
remember you saying that and i realized
while i was tripping okay i'm kind of
this is basically dark you need a pitch
black oh you need pitch blast oh okay
that curtain pitch black gotcha
coming in
the warehouse when we turn the lights
off oh [__] that's the kind of pitch
that's how dark you know you need
vintage muscle pitch
[__] movie what a [__] really
oh were they aliens
what was it killing them
it was a bad movie i don't know oh
terror movie sorry
so marty finally uh tripped out on
mushrooms congratulations welcome to the
[__] club we need to be the whole bar
next time and it's gonna be intense
you're gonna
my i know when i'm [__] up when i
start saying my own name in my head and
it makes no sense and i start thinking
of my own face and going why is that my
face oh and it gets wild and then you
remember that's just a shell and i'm
just looking at my body and that's where
i know i'm like
oh yeah here we go oh gosh i'm
contemplating my existence
[__] no i get the giggles hard and
that's when i know it's about to happen
oh yeah i've only got it twice where i
like start laughing on control i can't
hold it like
it's right here yeah it's it's
right here the idea of doing anything
other than [__] giggling was [__]
funny yes
or with my clothes when i touched them
and i've woken up and my clothes are so
stretched out because i keep touching
and pulling i'm like whoa it's all the
way at the ground
because like my perception gets so
[__] fish eye that i wake up and the
ends of my shirts are just tough i had
that a little bit i was sitting on the
couch and looking down at my feet like
i remember thinking like this
[__] just like thinking like i
don't know why i thought that like it
was funny to me
like you're the alien admitted black
controlling you now yeah yeah exactly
why'd they give them these ones
that's how i felt it did feel like that
a little bit yeah but once you get there
it's it's intense
but there was no way like i could do
anything like creative i expected to be
able to like
do something yeah i do a lot of
mushrooms and build up you your yeah
oh i need about three drinks i'll get on
stage with karaoke you need that like
i'll do about 500 five brands of
mushrooms i'm gonna [__] freak out
and do some art yeah yeah that's what
i'm looking for that's what i want
that's when you you have to build up
yeah you're not going to get them the
first time you know what i'm saying
i'm [__] high what time is it
118.
ah [__] one two 14. okay fine i'm way
off
um last thing
yesterday
oh two days ago
this weekend rosie and i went to las
vegas it was our 10-year anniversary
wild as [__] is our 10-year anniversary
from when we started [__] dating
weirdest [__] that's been that long
especially we're talking about all this
is cr i forgot about the paintings in
our house isn't that [__] up
i don't like that only that i forgot i
wish we would have been able to take
them but yeah
um so it's been 10 [__] years since
we've been dating which is really really
odd to say out loud it is right because
it feels like
no time it's because like no time has
gone by but then again at the same time
because we started the other date yeah
it's been like almost a lifetime pretty
soon you're gonna have been together
longer than not that's where me and
april are just realizing that
i mean like you'll have been together
longer in life than you weren't together
that's crazy
oh wow yeah ugh
that's wild another 12 years
you're 22. yeah yeah yeah damn dale whoa
that's crazy i mean april almost [__]
there it's not that far that's a trip
um
so we went to vegas did a bunch of [__]
which is the raider game
when me rosie go to regis normally
we don't do anything cool i mean
we do stop we plan on going to shows all
we end up doing is getting [__] up
going to strip clubs the whole time
that's it then we leave like six a.m
and we sleep all day and then we miss
vegas all day and then go out it's hot
and then we go
nowhere and go whoa let's go to a show
oh well the show's over well let's go to
this other strip club
and that's all we do and we get so
[__] up it's so much fun it's fun as
hell but we never do anything so this
time we were adults planned for adults
we did not go to any strip clubs this
time no co mainly because of covenant i
want to be around
hey come here stay over there come here
but come over here
a leaf i'ma go that's how i felt so we
went to the raider game the stadium was
[__] baller
uh which of the raider game
was awesome and then we went to see
circus olay right
the oh [__]
those guys look
i've never seen anything in i've never
seen physical things like that in my
life these fools doing flips and
launching themselves 50 feet in the air
it's just was mind-blowing yeah the
whole time i felt sick to my stomach
because i kept because we were in the
front row so i was i leveled to the
stage so it looked like
it looked like they're gonna smack the
stage yeah cause there's a pool there's
a retractable pool that goes in and it
comes in pieces but it does it on its
own so while this guy's going up he's he
was just standing on the stage and while
he's going up he falls the stage is now
and you're like oh my god he's gonna
[__] die it's like oh it's a pool now
but you didn't see it happen because it
retracts down uh-huh and when it goes up
it just goes over the water line oh [__]
see what i'm saying so it comes out we
saw later there's divers under there
helping everybody yeah
but it [__] me up
really bad like it was so scary to me
the whole time i was just sitting there
oh
were you off out of bowls in chateau no
i was just fearing for these people's
eyes bro
they're so high in the air it's like yo
one mistake you're not even attached to
a rope
they were attached to like a little not
all of them no not all of them that's
what [__] me up like yo your arm
strength is holding your life
man did you see the dude walk across
niagara falls on a rope that willendo's
no
anybody thinks tyropine is cool you're
in it yeah
i can't do that no one ever [__] got
a girl or some free weed for some
[__] time rope walking
let's say that right to that other side
and you're just alive and [__] yeah like
oh i live like oh me too on the other
side
stupid
[Music]
that person had no [__] danger in
their life that they're like yeah i'm
gonna [__] almost die i need to
almost die yeah no thank you yeah nobody
thought it was cool
[__]
thank you thank you so much cyclists
same thing goes for you oh god
all right unless you ride in the bike
lane then you're [__] tired you're in
shape and i wish i could be in that
shape but if not [__] you and you're out
of shape
thank you thank you
exactly
[__] yeah sorry guys that was perfect
here we go you know i've gotten into it
jesus's uh old friend remember i don't
remember his name damon
jebus has had a best friend and he did
not really [__] like me that much and
i didn't really like him that much my
best friend
he didn't really like me that much he
was never like rocker kids yeah he was
always kind of weird toward me he was he
was a little weird yeah he was always
kind of weird toward me like standoffish
and i was like all right [__] and i'm
very blunt when it comes to like hey
what you're doing now is [__] whack
and you're kind of mean i always you
know what i will [__] tell you if
you're my friend i don't give a [__]
sorry i will let you know that you're an
[__]
um anyway i started talking [__] about
cyclists didn't know that fool was
active cyclists and he started going
hard on me and i go but just to get out
of this tree it's made for everybody you
know logical like see that bike lane
that's yours that's your section if this
is a if we're sharing rooms this line is
my side yeah and that line is your side
of the room that's why they call it the
bike lane
thank you so that's what happened [__]
cyclist and that's see that's how much i
hate him we're talking about cyclists my
bad
anyway i feel like we're [__] those
old races and you know what else they're
taking our [__] jobs too
and our women
they're just taking our roads and our
right turns [__]
yeah you got to commit when you find
yourself buying spandex when you buy a
helmet that's a little longer than
normal you know you're either hal from
malcolm in the middle which is cool or
everyone else in the world that's not
[Laughter]
there's no other way to put it i can't
wait for these clips oh god they're
gonna be so erratic okay so we went to
circus olay everybody almost died it was
scary it was amazing we went to we got
this vegan spot
one of the worst i'm fat piece [__] my
whole life
well not my whole life i i came up to
the conclusion i was really poor and
skinny yeah always starving as a kid so
then that's why you feel like you have
to eat everything on your plate like
dude it's like a thing in my brain the
second i got back from my grandma she's
like what you guys didn't want to eat
you go
we can pick what the [__] we wanna eat
oh my god and my grandma never let up
she's like yo you want to eat this three
times a day
yeah
because remember they were trying to
call cps and my mom because we weren't
eating we were [__] stick figures and
you put the chain on the door on the
fridge
these are tweakers and [__]
and then uh with a lock on it anyway
so i think like every time i see food as
after that i'm like yo eat it all
because the next time you eat you might
it might be two days
you know what i mean like it might be a
while so that's how i felt my whole life
so that's when i started getting
i became a fat kid right when we came
back i was a stick figure my whole life
until that day i came back and just like
i was always a fat kid and i think
that's why
first time in my life i went and ordered
food at this place in vegas and i went
left the whole plate i can't eat that
and i'm not going to i need to get food
she took one [__] bite of her food
and like there's raw onions and
fettuccine
and not like diced small onions like
sliced onions
which is odd yeah and we asked her can
you cook it more you were mortified you
called me from there you're like yeah oh
we did and then she's like it's not your
fault don't worry but can you just cook
it more it's like oh don't worry were we
making it she just said no onions yeah
and she brought it back and it was worse
they remade it like that onion plate it
smelled like a plate of onions she took
a bite with it's gross i'd take a bite
with don't eat that [__]
i paid 100 something dollars and the
best thing was the [__] soda that i
drink
damn
that was very sad you must oh because
you don't i still tipped the lady though
because she was super cool oh she was so
nice she was really nice she felt like
she should you don't want a box are they
going okay with the check two full
plates of food we're looking at it like
i'm like i'm just trying to go i just
want to get the [__] out i felt super
weird and bad about it i've never wasted
food in my life
and i wasted food that day you know that
i do not weigh [__] i wasted two plates
of fettuccine bro i felt so bad it looks
so good it was bad anyway that was that
first night i woke up the next day and
rosie booked this spa
that we ordered terrible burgers too oh
man
service and then we got these veggie
burgers which is cool we got these
nachos and it was like [__] the
weirdest [__]
two bites went bro he's made twenty five
dollars for climbing
what's those olives called nuts
in my nacho and anyway we're all here
complaining
but vegas is supposed to be like a vegan
haven right now yeah it's supposedly
like one of the top rated spots and the
spot we went to eating our food was
rated five stars number one place in
vegas for vegan food number one
i looked it up in everything number one
right here
great
great reviews everything and then it was
weird tons of friends tell me oh yeah go
there forever it was weird bro
it was so odd my uh biscuits and gravy
tastes like the top ramen powder that
you add on your chopped ramen yeah it's
just salt and like seasoned went mmm
this is bad it was so bad anyway we
ordered the impossible berries and i'm
over here writing lady a tip that
brought the food and i look at my
receipt after i go
this [__]
[__] 20 gratuity and a nine dollar
charge for you to bring it i just gave
you 40 dollars damn you played me
because it's already added oh you [__]
anyway um it was a hundred and something
dollars we ate two impossible burgers
and pieces of bread
with two pieces of vegan cheese and
ketchup and then ketchup on it nice
and then the next morning was our
anniversary
and rosie
booked the spa [__]
it was really cool we did the spa thing
at the win it was baller as [__] we're
there all [__] day basically it was
really cool
and then
we went to dinner at this place when
we'll stay in the place okay it's a
really fancy ass restaurant
like yeah that vegan a menu like cool
menus and we go there man and rosie's
food i'm like oh your food looks thai
and i get mine i'm like wait i thought
it was like a plate of pasta or whatever
it was just two pieces of gardein
chicken breaded sardine is the nasty
boxed
i don't like the chicken yeah it's like
a soy chicken and it was just breaded on
a plate with two pieces of it forty
dollars
sorry thirty nine
it was thirty nine dollars same
difference um
this is the i got a soda there and no
one's preparing oh no i got the drink
there i got the drink there was good
delicious no thank you no
so i didn't finish my food again i just
took a couple bites of one piece and
went oh i'm [__] cool
i felt really horrible and i said oh man
i'm wasting food like a piece of [__]
first off
then what we went to
absinthe if you ever go to vegas go to
the apps in the show the guy that hosts
it is a [__]
his co-host had they're so [__] funny
oh my god it's a comedy show mixed in
with acrobatic [__] but the guy that
hosts it is the guy that created the
show and he's [__] hysterical he's
hilarious that [__] is funny as
[__] and his girl that his like
assistant chick was super funny anyway
we went there i was amazed the whole
time it's such a small stage too yeah it
was like this big and they're doing all
this crazy [__] on it dude it was crazy
then we went to a super cool rated vegan
spot right after and we get there
and we we get
let's go right to the restaurant so we
can go to the bathroom because you can't
go in the [__] hotel uh because we're
not in our hotel anymore we're at the
[__] show
and we get there and there's no indoor
dining it's a room bigger than this
whole entire building it's a restaurant
business we don't do indoor dining until
next year we're still renovating and i
looked damn like it's done
anyway we ordered our [__]
and as soon as i
tipped he's like you know what i'm
feeling generous i tipped her way more
than i should have she didn't seem too
nice this white chick
rosie's sitting over there with a dress
we just came from all the [__] stores
we have like a bag we look like bougie
[__] [__] we did you know i'm
saying i get it
but i'm super polite well thank you all
of all have this
and it's like do you want your drinks
right now i go uh i'll take the
milkshake before at all because we're
getting it to go because there's [__]
no dining and it's freezing outside
everyone's gonna dress i'm over you're
trying to like
it's cold [__]
and then she goes i go i'll take the
milk she goes well i gotta make it first
just like that to me and i went
oh yeah i know no [__]
and i turned around and went
i thought this tipped you back
when i turned around i knew something
was wrong
she looked at me like you know you know
up is up and down is down stupid [__]
that's the way she looked at me that's
how i felt she talked to me and went
i just tipped you so ah
i even said i might just call the
[__] bank and tell him to cancel that
[__] d i was so aggravated i've never
heard him say that in my life before
either i was like usually
just let it go like no i don't want that
[__] [__] to spend that [__] on weed
or any [__] her just the way she said
that [__] i have to make it first
oh really
[__]
that's when i say [__] yeah no yeah not
that some girl some [__] at the [__]
front yeah anyway um some guys look like
she was looked [__] miserable she was
a [__] [__]
and then some dude pulled up some goofy
big tall dude
and he's super nice so nice just been
helped
oh you look like that girl that's your
little sister and she hates working for
you that's what just happened afterwards
she was a little nicer when he showed up
she started being okay after she came to
the window i'll be just a few minutes
two minutes ago oh
you [__] [__] this is how [__]
people this is how racists are made all
right for real this is how it happens
like this is
this is what i was talking about
talking about
[__] [__] up but now for real i felt
so played we went back and i almost
threw up
uh when i started eating the sandwich
almost puked it was my food was pretty
good hershey was cool
so remember let's get it to [__]
together i didn't finish any of the food
i still haven't eaten it's been two days
yet right the story i still haven't like
eaten any plate and
i've taken bites of stuff because we
went to plant power after before
before we left so we get our [__]
food the other night we wake up and go
to plant power and plant power is a
place we go in la all the time so we
just went somewhere we're like yo let's
not just be sad and disappointed and i'm
[__] starving it's been two days yeah
i told rosie we went on vacation i lost
[__] weight we were gonna try this
other place but we were too
nervous remember the taco spot yeah but
anyway i'm sorry for all the complaints
but this is literally a [__] seinfeld
episode anniversary recap seinfeld style
so the one time we're like let's be
adults and go all these places like yo
we should just throw [__] money at
naked [__] yeah and make reservations
uh yeah i instead of eating i would have
just went to this chip club spent it on
then now you know now i know vegas is
for strip clubs yep
shows and strip clubs yeah
for food
for us next t-shirt don't eat there
vegas is for strip clubs and
naked women
that's it
same thing just reiterating it's for
strip clubs and there's naked women
inside
i don't know that's what john would say
i know
that's exactly what he would say oh
sorry that was our trip for vegas
anniversary hey you did really good you
you've been here for over an hour i know
this what time is it
1 30.
exactly rosie you did an hour and a half
you could have done your whole episode
you got to do your whole episode
okay
it's not that bad it's not bad it was
fine right oh yeah but i'm okay now
because it's just us having a
conversation yeah we do this every day
when i forget and like look good yeah
yeah you look past the camera because
you don't want to go looking for the
camera once you get rolling it's fine
yeah but what are the odds we'll just
put a caveat on that what are the
[__] odds right
i have a super significant 10-year
anniversary i know on the same exact day
as your guys's 10-year anniversary
that's when i realized i was like oh
that's [__] weird i didn't know all
this [__] about your dad yeah me either
yeah well i mean if you follow me on
instagram you already know this he got
inducted into the buffalo music hall of
fame and i accepted his award on his
behalf
on the same day 10 years yeah the exact
same day
popped up on my facebook that that event
happened like
on your guys crazy i didn't know you had
a picture of cam in a suit
i showed thomas i go look at cam
holy [__]
this was like cam that was so odd bro
that's funny it's like
one of the only times i've ever worn
like a tie and a suit and [__]
yeah but that was cool yeah i like it
was that was really a trippy night it
was me jamal april my mom a couple
hundred people on this big like
you know venue and [__] and my godfather
and my dad got inducted the same at the
same time oh [__] so my godfather who
was his bandmate like introduced me and
[__] and i went i don't even remember
what the [__] i just freestyled the
speech
for
yeah yeah
and my dad you know i love my dad i love
my dad
[Laughter]
but yeah that that [__] was trippy when
i realized that like damn what are the
odds odds of that yeah
significant wild marathon
yeah that was the other thing that was
that was really in a marathon after i
didn't yeah he had a full marathon in
south buffalo that was like in his honor
and like all those are words i have them
at my house now we got bro there's a lot
of [__] awards there was and they're
from like the senate the
erie county legislator
like they gave them a day
they yeah it was like is it charlie
o'neill day there was and like the year
after that he died when the the day of
that marathon like
holy [__] so cool
yeah that [__] was crazy it's crazy to
feel like yeah i'm going to show my kids
and stuff no it's wild you know what
that date is
eleven
two two eleven
one one two two i never realized that
yeah that's the day we got together
everything perfectly lined up sync like
just syncing together that's some
synchronicity type [__] one one two two
one one isn't that some [__]
yeah
for number all your number [__]
out there that's some dope [__] um you
know what we mean what a wild ass day
yeah to all happen on
um
you know this is this is a long episode
i [__] love it yeah you can do your
own episode so whenever you get
comfortable we'll do that we'll do the
episode so now guys this is just a
like when mortal kombat when you you hit
that fool and he goes
yep exactly that's one of these for
rosie i wanted to do this too because
now april has to do it too yes april has
to do it
you know anytime you call me or facetime
you know i'm [__] with april that's
what it would be
yeah you know yeah
oh i'm ready for it all right yeah i'm
ready for that
we should switch
over here
[Laughter]
somehow i defend the [__] out of
somebody that's easy
gabe you gabe there's too many office
references
anyways
um so before we leave i have a question
and i think it's a really good one
you ready it's not on the notes i
thought of this
ready
we have a girl what are you naming her
if you have a boy
[Music]
wow if we have a boy of course i would
like to name him wallace and we've
talked about that but i just love that
name okay look it i love the name
wallace
favorite boy name for some reason but
that's my grandpa's name that's her
grandpa's [__] name my grandpa worked
for opie wallace his whole life opie
wallace is the only reason my grandpa
and anybody ever had any money mm-hmm
and that's the checking company in my
town okay which is gross if you guys
remember from the valley wallace that's
my grandfather's like he was my
opi wallace my grandpa was like we were
like [__] that because my grandpa
came here in the 50s on that when the
first mexican people were allowed to
work my grandpa led the [__] work
shift
so it's
i learned about it and like
that's my [__] grandpa i've heard
about it it's [__] college
turns out that was my [__] grandpa
the guy that we were talking about and
that's some [__] crazy
[__] wild so wallace i always loved
the name
that's what i've always wanted to name
if i had a son it's just such a cool
name yeah wallace river it's hard it is
it's amazing it's going to be wally is
it going to be i don't care about wally
i just like the name wallace that's what
my grandpa's sister used to call him all
the time wally yeah i didn't know i've
i've been saying this name so i was like
12. i'd love that name and that's her
grandpa that's my grandfather's oh [__]
wild yeah
i like it as is wallace is a solid name
yeah that's it right
it's timeless it is sick um for a girl i
have no idea sharkeisha
her middle name no we me and john were
thinking of before memphis was born we
were thinking of names and i remember
travoltron
we're like what about travoltarons like
voltron and john travolta and he's like
what about travolt we said it
travolta
no it wasn't real okay but that's the
one we called memphis
trouble
you were almost revolted
sorry girl not your voltron sharkeesha
i don't know i think girl we should call
her what shania twain as the first name
the first name is
whoopi goldberg
first name i knew you weren't going to
be serious right
what what girl name i don't i haven't
thought of a girl named can i ever think
of girl names let's think of like
uncommon ones star
astrid ash street
there you go all right what are there
some
common ones
um
sharkeisha
we can't do that no i don't know
because i mean i did love her too i'm
not gonna lie
mar lawrence played chennai this is all
if you have a daughter named shane
you're gonna be the god parent
okay you're gonna be the god mother
though okay i'll do the baptism you're
the god godmother
you have to be you have to be that's the
rule now um
i don't know
daddy
that would be such a cool name that is a
great name it would be cool yeah this is
my favorite from petey herman for sure
that's such a good idea marty you just
named her daughter thanks
for i love that name i love it it's
great
my view looks all right
our nephew yo as soon as these kids are
born get just get ready i'm gonna be
stiff-worming people stiff-arming little
kids
our kids i know you're talking about our
own kids
like yo you trying to wrestle oh
if we have two kids on the team they
better have strong backs
they will when i do that [__] to them
they're going to work out with cam
that's how i'm going to get them in
their car seat as i'm going to do that's
going to be their training cam's going
to put them on workouts
because he didn't call me he said
nothing just text me the words i read
them and went
sounds right my brain processed it
and i read it out
had to make sure loud wasn't tripping
marty's son how old is he nine seven
oh my god is he really seven
he's a monster cam is a monster he's a
beast of a [__]
athlete kid
all he does is work out he's a seven
yeah and that's because i just saw his
room so i had the whole image in my head
marty's like yo i bought all these water
bottles together these big jugs and he's
like i just found him in [__] cam's
room because he's been lifting them
he couldn't find his uh sandball so he's
been looking around water like
in me
man i called him a [__] inmate the
first time when i walked in and i had
bought the bench press the squat rack
thing the towels and we didn't have any
weights yet he put [__] towels
on it and dirty clothes to weigh it down
get up
he's racking up
what
your kid's crazy
he is [__] insane he's gonna start
[__] pressing me for my breakfast and
[__]
i'm driving to school i'm joking the
[__] you gonna do about it you're going
to work i'm going to work he's seven
years old i thought he was [__]
almost dead yeah
he's he's i know he let him he was sick
you feel like a piece of [__] i don't
know
i gotta get on my shirt he's like that
[__] uh that workout black dude that
joe rogan always talks about he runs
david goggins thank you he's like that
guy he's seven
coaching his dad up and [__] no he's
doing that to himself in his room all
right what you're gonna want to do is
you squat but he records himself for
youtube yeah he does
yeah he's awesome hey cam newton
hmm
cam newton watch out watch out watch out
no i'm saying cam
ed mccabe or ed mccaffery's kid
christian mccaffrey that's cam
number 22 that's cam number 22.
um
okay
cool
cool that's a long episode
that was good we are
we are [__] for traffic oh yeah 100 oh
it's bad what time is it i'm gonna say 3
40.
it's 4 20. no it's not yeah
we're screwed we're gonna have to like
go around
because you know today's like the worst
day to drive to you i know it's the
worst day in in america
they showed this on the news and one
time me and thomas were like that was us
we were we've been stuck in it before oh
my god rosie we're gonna go around okay
we're gonna go through the mountains
this time four [__] 20. i said we
have to be out here at 140 the latest
be safe out there driving i did it you
did a good job yeah good job
see i need i need headsets back there so
i can hear it so you know what's going
on every time i go what the [__]
something like that yeah
all right good episode all right
thanksgiving holiday episode i guess
uh this is the monday after so if you're
at school like i said keep it up there's
only a few more weeks then you're going
to christmas vacation if you're at work
you're an adult so [__] off and you have
to be at work sorry keep it together
do your thing we all do it
we all did it
you have to
there's no time there's no two weeks off
all right unless you're a baller and
then
what job do you have that's sick let us
know yeah let me know it's tight
um what else what else drive
careful
don't get in fights with any of your
family members
this christmas and if you did try to
apologize maybe yeah i guess okay but
you know i have people i don't [__]
tolerate either no
i feel you uh
anything else you want to add no what
the [__] your daughter's name i
thought we went over dottie oh yeah
i'm high
i'm sitting here doing this today we
still didn't have it marty named her kid
i forgot
okay
also twins running my family heavy
we're just gonna put that out there and
there's no twins in his
generation you gotta do lottie and
dottie if there's two of them
that's hard oh my god
he's so [__] sick
that'd be hilarious it's hard
i like that a lot it is not going to
happen i'm not going to do that
i like the concept of it i like the
thought of being like oh that's an
option yeah my grandpa was a twin
so
um
keep that in mind
all right it's possibility that one day
we have children that there's two of
them pray for me that way i can get it
over faster yeah oh that i just want to
be like yo see
see i'm gonna [__] people's minds up at
the store i'm gonna dress you the same
i'm gonna [__] everybody up
oh gosh i can just imagine the things
you could do with a double person
just wait
just like a double person just be
prepared mercy it's going to mess with
you i'm going to redo the double
gum
commercials could it's just a kid
the most boring commercial ever i'm
sorry let's get off this topic uh cool
we are done this has been the episode
the first time we've ever bleeped in a
person okay
legendary cool you guys finally there it
is so
now that you're more comfortable we'll
work on it more and when you're ready
we'll do a whole episode okay do
something cool
marty
[__] yeah anything else you want to say
i'm happy we made this happen so highly
requested and
feels right the 10-year anniversary of
thanksgiving and [__] you know it just
felt right to do this
perfect time yeah timing worked out
perfect actually
oh my god okay time to
be in traffic go to traffic and go to
thanksgiving tomorrow
it's tomorrow
it's cool
all right let's do this
guys
please be safe
if you're listening to this right now
it's monday
thanksgiving's over it's okay like i
said christmas is coming
be safe
have fun
don't fight
what else don't get arrested don't get
arrested
out there have you oh yeah they are they
are the [__] out there they followed my
barber here the eiffel tower they
followed our barber here the other day
because he was like he's a street racer
and he's in his car they followed him
all the way up until i opened the door
and they saw and then they left they
were just looking at him right there in
front of our parking
what i forgot to tell you yeah they
followed him all the way here and they
went oh
oh it's he really does go in here you
know oh he really didn't just pull into
some place oh wow yeah
uh be safe all right don't street race
you guys be safe um
i we have no time but the rims are on
the car i gotta go see it i gotta go see
it in person we still have to stop by
the rental cars i know
i know guys thank you so much for
watching thank you for being here
everything coming out soon if you're
still here thank you for being live chat
please don't forget to leave a like that
[__] really [__] helps the algorithm
since youtube does not want to you know
suggest any of our videos anymore it's
okay
it's okay that's why i keep saying it's
okay okay
sorry
we see it all right
[Music]
it's cool it's like when you like let
somebody like you do favor for somebody
and they're like yo can you pick that up
because of my background [__] you all
right okay [__] you it's easy for you
all you gotta do is press a button
we'll see
we'll see what happens
i don't know why i went so deep into
that but i was about to say five more
things away no way i'm on the platform
let me just chill out dude i'm just
really high and out of it i think is
what it is i'm over here trying to end
the show
you know what i would do
you know
are you is it because i'm proud gonna
start saying that all the time is it
because i'm brown i'm just gonna use
that card forever there's white
privilege i'm gonna start using is it is
it because you're racist
even though it's not it's still funny to
you [__] i'm gonna start flexing that
[__] guys you know uh
real quick what's that motherfucker's
name the ufc fighter king k velasquez
yeah with brown pride on his back
oh crazy crazy right tattoo okay i'm
gonna start start the reason you're
saying this is because that's how we got
the [__] youtube channel turned back
on
maybe you don't want to go too hard
all right that's right maybe you don't
want to go too hard on the platform
we're talking about
all i did was ask a question
the question went a simple question
activate all right
okay yeah i was wondering yeah no that's
cool i was wondering
just i was just wondering
uh this piece of [__] i knew
uh i don't [__] with it anymore said
something really really really
significant one time and he was like yo
you can call people spake you can do
whatever you can downgrade people's
ethnicities because
he said but white people the only thing
you can do and the worst thing you can
say to him is call them a racist
and it went whoa
that's a crazy statement that is true it
doesn't hit as hard for the other races
but isn't that crazy like wow the worst
thing you can do is tell somebody
they're [__] evil and everyone knows
it
you know what if you're like yo coffee
he's gonna
be called an evil person
you're getting an average white person
on their [__] heels you do that right
off the bat oh [__] oh my [__]
friends are black
[Music]
but it's it's just yeah
it's funny anyway came velasquez rocking
that brown prize someone started doing
all these platforms that [__] with me
tick-tock
[__] i already talked about it guys
thank you so much thank you so much i'm
over here
i'm in traffic right now is what i'm
saying like i'm sitting here just oh my
god i should have thought about that
before i ended the [__] show thinking
about the hours okay here we go guys
thank you so much for watching the
double usual podcast the reason it's not
ending well is because i'm with two
people i talk to all [__]
and i forget that we have to actually
wrap this thing up and we're not just
talking
thank you thank you thank you thank you
thank you thank you guys thank you
thank you too
guys appreciate you so much this has
been dope as usual podcast have a best
day
oh my god the [__]
ad read marty remember remember the
three-hour podcast
and on the worst traffic day in american
history
[Music]
perfect